bien et ben nous allons pouvoir euh
commencer notre
audition qui va clôturer un peu un cycle
du mois de septembre qui était intense
et qui nous a tous mobiliser pendant des
dizaines et des dizaines d'heures mais
des auditions particulièrement
intéressantes et dans la chronologie
monsieur le ministre c'est aujourd'hui
que nous vous auditionnons avec des
membres de votre
cabinet Grégory em votre conseiller et
margaot bonau qui est conseillère
parlementaire les excuses bien sûr du
président Milon président de cette
commission d'enquête également président
de la commission des affaires sociales
mais retenu sur son département alors
Monsieur le Ministre notre commission
d'enquête a une particularité c'est
qu'elle se tient pas à postériori mais
en même temps que les événements qui
nous réunissent et euh nous avons euh
tous en tête le triptique défini par
l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe protéger tester
isolé la pénurie d'équipement
d'équipement de protection a été
abondamment commentée sur les tests
après une lente montée en puissance la
France en réalise désormais un nombre
important 1,2 million chaque semaine
dont certains de par le délai deviennent
tout à fait
inutiles et quant à l'isonnement il
semble que ce levier soit très peu
miliser par rapport à la quarantaine
donc un certain nombre de questions se
pose je vais vous demander comme il est
de tradition de tenir un propos
liminaire si vous le souhaitez bien sûr
dans un délai contraint d'une dizaine de
minutes de façon à laisser place aux
questions de nos trois rapporteurs au
départ puis les questions groupé de nos
commissaires
alors comme il s'agit d'une commission
d'enquête vous connaissez bien la
procédure l'amende en cas de propos
mensonger de 15000 € avec une peine de
prison pouvant aller jusque 5 ans et je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité de lever
la main droite et de dire je le jure je
le jure ceci étant fait monsieur le
ministre je vous laisse la parole pour
minutes monsieur le vice-président cher
René Paul Savari Mesdames et Messieurs
les les rapporteurs mesdames Messieurs
les sénatrices sénateurs
avant de commencer j'aimerais évidemment
rendre un
hommage un hommage à celles et ceux qui
ont fait face à cette crise en première
ligne dans nos hôpitaux dans nos épades
en médecine de ville sans oublier
évidemment les professionnels du
domicile et toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont permis à la France de résister
au choc et de tenir
j'associe particulièrement dans le
contexte actuel à mon hommage l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques qui ont pu voir
ou qui peuvent
revoir leur activité professionnelle
impacter par la gestion de crise je sais
combien un certain nombre de mesures
peuvent être difficiles à appréhender
pour des personnes qui font des efforts
depuis des semaines depuis des mois et
qui ne sont pas responsables de la
situation épidémique mais qui font
l'objet de mesure de gestion pour
protéger les populations je veux leur
redire que l'État est là pour eux comme
il l'a été depuis le premier jour et
comme il le sera jusqu'à la fin de cette
gestion de
crise je vais aussi rendre hommage et
dire vraiment ma gratitude sincère à
l'ensemble des agents des
administrations centrales des agences
régionales de santé de tous les services
de l'État j''y associe aussi les
pompiers les réserves civiques les
réserves sanitaires mais également les
agents des forces de
l'ordre policiers les gendarmes qui sont
mobilisés pour faire respecter des
règles dans des conditions difficiles eu
aussi depuis le depuis le premier
jourengagement a été exceptionnel ils
ont chaque jour forcé mon admiration
cette crise sanitaire monsieur le
sénateur mesames et messieurs les
sénateurs je la vis depuis le premier
jour de mon entrée en fonction le 16
février dernier j'ai été nommé ministre
alors que le virus circulait depuis peu
il y avait des personnes infectées il y
avait des foyers identifiés la menace
était réelle en franchissant les portes
de mon ministère je n'ignoris pas cette
menace et je n'ignorais pas le risque
d'une déferlante
épidémique nous allons parler ensemble
des choix qui ont été faits des choix
difficile lourd et je le reconnais
parfois
pénible je viens devant vous avec
humilité parce que l'humilité c'est un
vaccin c'est un vaccin efficace contre
les prophéties hasardeuse et les
jugements à
l'emporte-pièce je ne viens pas non plus
ici partager une opinion je viens
décrypter avec vous les chemins que nous
avons empruntés depuis le premier jour
dans un contexte d'incertitude jamais
égalé dans notre histoire contemporaine
un contexte dans lequel il s'est agit
d'apporter des réponses à des problèmes
qui se sont présentés chaque jour devant
nous je n'ai jamais été dans la posture
de celui qui fait des paris de celui qui
dit tout haut et sans F filtre tout ce
que la crise pourrait lui
inspirer surtout je me suis efforcé
d'écouter les avis nombreux qui se sont
exprimés faire le tri entre le bon grain
et l'ivret a été en quelque sorte mon
sacerdoce tandis qu'au même moment les
Français attendaient légitimement des
réponses
fermes dans une épidémie comme celle que
nous traversons le temps est un allié et
les connaissances d'aujourd'hui ne sont
pas celles d'hier il pourrait être
tantant de lire les stratégies prises
hier à l'ône des connaissances
d'aujourd'hui et je vous demande donc de
tenir du compte du caractère évolutif de
ces
connaissances de la même manière le
temps politique n'est pas le temps
scientifique et cette donnée ne doit pas
échapper aux échanges que nous
aurons rechercher la la vérité à la
lumière des faits c'est ce à quoi nous
nous attelons aujourd'hui et je ne doute
pas que cette exercice servira autant la
justesse du regard que nous portons sur
le passé récent que l'efficacité de
l'action que nous menons aujourd'hui
encore contre
l'épidémie en somme ma mission
elle est de gérer la crise
elle est de la gérer aujourd'hui elle
est de la gérer demain et devant vous
aujourd'hui elle est aussi de la gérer
hier nous avons tous en tête les images
de nos services de réanimation les
images des transferts sanitaires les
images d'un système de santé mis en
tension comme jamais ces images ne sont
pas de lointains souvenir et nous
faisons aujourd'hui tout notre possible
pour qu'elle ne se reproduise pas
l'épidémie n'est pas derrière nous et je
souhaite que nous gardions tous à
l'esprit pendant cette audition que
l'événement n'est pas passé que des
Français meurent toujours aujourd'hui du
coronavirus je le dis je le répète tous
les jours la vigilance n'est pas une
option et faire la lumière sur les
événements récents c'est aussi ne pas
s'aveugler sur la prégnance et la
persistance du
risque à ce titre je dois dire que je
suis le les travaux de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale j'ai vu un certain
nombre de résumés d'auditions hélas mes
journées sont déjà bien trop rempli pour
pouvoir suivre en intégralité les
auditions et j'ai trouvé beaucoup de
qualité dans plusieurs prises de de
position et intervention qui éclaire
aussi la façon de gérer les choses et je
vous en
remercie ma situation est singulière
aussi vous le savez puisque je suis
arrivé au moment où un point de non
retour avait déjà été atteint ce point
de non retour c'est circulation du virus
ce sont des foyers épidémiques déjà
constitués et qui allaient devenir peu
contrôlable et que nous n'étions pas
alors en capacité de connaître à
l'époque alors rassurez-vous je ne suis
pas là pour me défausser sur qui que ce
soit je ne suis pas là pour vous dire
que sommes toutes nous avons fait ce que
nous avons pu avec les moyens du bord je
suis là parce que nous devons toutes et
tous apprendre d'une crise qui a placé
la santé publique au cœur de nos
préoccupations je suis devant vous parce
que le Parlement doit être et est une
force motrice dans les politiques de
protection et de prévention je suis là
parce que je suis le ministre des
Solidarités et de la santé à ce poste
depuis le premier jour j'ai toujours agi
et j'ai toujours parlé avec
responsabilité et en toute transparence
je ne choisirai pas évidemment une autre
ligne aujourd'hui devant vous je vous je
vous remercie et je vais répondre à vos
questions merci pour ces propos liminire
monsieur le ministre donc nous
enchaînons avec les questions de
Catherine
desoch merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le le ministre
pour vos vos propos on a énormément de
de questions je pense les uns comme les
autres à à vous poser parce qu'à la fois
depuis le le votre arrivée en fonction
après le le départ d'agès Buzin et la
situation actuelle puisque hier vous
avez même fait des annonces fortes donc
beaucoup beaucoup de questions je vais
essayer de de les les centrés
sur trois ou quatre points sachant que
mes collègues auront beaucoup de
questions à suivre dans des domaines
variés comme les vaccins la télémédecine
bien sûr les tests et autres moi j'avais
une première question hier nous avons
entendu agès Buzin qui nous a fait un
déroulé très précis et très
chronologique de ce qui s'était passé
entre le janvier les premiers cas en
Chine et et le moment où elle a quitté
le ministère TER et elle est le
sentiment que j'ai tiré de son audition
c'était que en effet il y avait elle
avait eu une une intuition que que les
choses allaient
évoluer qu'elle avait à ses yeux bien
préparés et qu'elle est partie nous
a-t-elle dit en ayant conscience d'avoir
bien bordé et balisé certains
points donc comment vous lorsque vous
êtes arrivé quelle situation vous avez
trouvé et quel le qu'est-ce qui a fait
qu'il a pu apparaître des lenteurs ou
une une mise en route si je puis dire
des de l'appareil d'État
euh avec un retard par rapport à ce
qu'elle a pu nous expliquer ça c'était
ma première question deuxième question
qui a été un point qui revient souvent
et qui revient encore ça a été pourquoi
dès le départ a-t-on orienté vers le
SAMU et en laissant des pan entiers de
la médecine de ville de côté alors
certes il y aussi c'était l'idée de ne
pas envoyer les patients chez leur
médecins généraliste il y avait aussi ce
qui a joué bien évidemment les manque de
protection pour les personnels de
médecine de ville pour tous les
professionnels de santé de ville mais
est-ce qu'on aurait pas dû dès le départ
laisser une partie de la médecine de
ville suivre ces patients symptomatique
plutôt que d'engorger les hôpitaux comme
on l'a fait avec les les patients ça
c'était ma de deuxème question et quelle
est la place actuelle de de la médecine
de ville
euh comment vous vous souhaitez leur
donner peut-être plus de moyens ou plus
de facilité dans la prise en charge
notamment des des tests ça c'était ma de
le deuxème point 3è point ce sont sur
quoi vous appuyez au au fil des semaines
sur quel conseil scientifique vous
appuyez alors pas conseil scientifique
au sens du conseil scientifique présidé
par professeur frécis mais quelles sont
les données scientifiques sur lesquelles
vous appuyez on a entendu beaucoup
parler de l'OMS et en disant on a fait
ça au moment où l'OMS disait de le faire
on se rend compte que la gestion de
l'OMS qui va d'ailleurs faire l'objet
d'un audit peut par certains points
prêter à discussion ça c'était mon
troisème point et enfin je terminerai
sur les plans hospitaliers on les a tous
vécus il y a eu cette première vague du
Grand Est il y a eu ensuite la région
parisienne euh et d'autres régions qui
mais ça on l'a vu après on ne savait pas
au départ qui ont attendu une vague qui
à l'époque n'est pas arrivée il y a eu
donc un un renoncement au soins pour
plusieurs raisons les les annulations
d'intervention le fait que les les
patients les les patients ne
souhaitaient pas forcément aller un
manque aussi de d'équipement euh où
est-ce qu'on en est actuellement et dans
cette situation à une mesure forte ne
craignez-vous pas euh ou du moins
comment allez-vous Pier
euh le fait qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y
ait un nouveau renoncement aux soins
pour des pathologies sérieuses notamment
je pense en en cancérologie ou en en
pathologie cardio-vasculaire euh je
pense et puis quel est le retour
d'expérience dernier point quel est le
retour d'expérience est-ce que au fil
des semaines vous faites un vrai retour
d'expérience pour pouvoir donner des
préconisations ou au médecins de ville
aux soignants de ville mais aussi aux
hôpitaux qui ne sont pas forcément
demand à la pointe des services de
réanimation ou d'hôpitaux universitaires
pour qu'il tire justement profit de ce
qui a été fait auaravant et qu'il n'y
ait pas à nouveau un tâonnement ou du
temps perdu à essayer de à essayer de
d'avoir une une procédure bien claire je
vous
remercie beaucoup de questions madame la
sénatrice de roche auquel je vais tenter
de
répondre la situation à mon arrivée
elle est celle effectivement d'un pays
qui se prépare à la
possibilité d'une épidémie d'un virus
inconnu en provenance de Chine lors même
que l'épidémie factuellement n'existait
ni en France ni en
Europe plusieurs semaines avant mon
arrivée déjà avait été identifié la
cellule de crise le Corus avait été
publiés les premiers bulletins
d'information à l'ensemble des
structures sanitaires aux agences
régionales de C la ministre agès Buzin
avait déjà fait plusieurs interventions
publiques pour parler du virus dire
qu'il y avait des possibilités que ce
virus puisse rentrer même si il n'y
avait pas de certitude à l'époque et en
fait mon premier contact avec l'épidémie
je n'étais pas ministre j'étais député
de Grenoble et il se trouve qu'au C de
Grenoble était hospitalisé un monsieur
anglais ainsi que ses enfants qui avait
été dans le closur de contamine
montgeoie et la ministre agè Buzin
sétant rendu à la rencontre c'était sur
ma circonscription je suis médecin
également dans cet hôpital je l'ai
naturellement accompagné je suis allé à
la rencontre des équipes de Médecins du
service de maladie infectieus qui
avaient mis en place l'isolement
hospitalier des personnes malades et et
qu'à contact en l'occurrence ces
personnes avaient des symptômes qui
s'apparentait pour le coup à un rhume il
n'avait pas eu de forme grave à
contamine Monjoie j' pu par ailleurs
constater que l'ensemble des
dispositions et la grande réactivité à
contamine monjois avec la capacité
d'isoler les cas contact de fermer les
structures qui nécessitient d'être
fermées de tester les populations qui
nécessitent d'être testé et un grand
nombre de tests avaient été réalisés
tous négatifs en dehors de quelques
personnes positives 5 ou six au total
qui avaiit fréquenté le même chalet que
la personne qui revenait de de Singapour
et qui avait transmis le virus
surcontamine monjois donc un cluster qui
aurait pu démarrer très fort contamine
manjour aurait pu être le début d'une
épidémie précoce avant l'Italie il l'a
pas été parce que la gestion a été
optimale du début à la fin je le dis
d'autant plus que j''étais que
parlementaire et certainement pas aux
commandes sin n avz pas eu la vigilance
des médecins dans cette station de ski
n'y avait pas eu déjà des communications
internationales pour pouvoir dire
attention il y a eu des cas qui sont qui
peuvent éventuellement avoir transmis le
virus sur le territoire national s'il
avait pas eu la préparation de l'agence
régionale de santé de la région auverg
ronalp et s'il n'y avait pas eu déjà la
préparation des équipes hospitalières
pour pouvoir accueillir dans les
conditions optimales des patients en
isolement contamine Monjoie aurait pu
tout à fait être le départ d'une
épidémie bien plus précoce pour moi
c'est la marque d'un pays qui avait su
se
préparer il y avait déjà le
déclenchement du stade 1 du plan Hsan ce
que la ministre agès Buzin vous a dit
hier le 14 février avant mon arrivée le
jour où le premier décès avait été
enregistré le Stade 2 sera déclenché par
mes soins de semaines plus tard
consistant à renforcer les mesures de
confinement pour les foyers de
propagation notamment dans looise où
nous avions dû fermer des écoles et
interdire des rassemblements et au
niveau national où nous avons interdit
les manifestations supérieur à 5000
personnes en milieu fermé donc la
préparation du du système de santé je le
dis et je rends hommage à l'action qui a
été conduite par ma prédécesseur euh
elle était réelle et je peux vous dire
madame la ministre que lorsqu'elle vous
dit en commission d'enquête hier qu'elle
était sans doute la mieux préparée des
pays environnants métant rendu moi-même
quelques jours après ma nomination à
Rome pour rencontrer des ministres de la
Santé et 2 semaines après ma nomination
à Bruxelles pour discuter avec
l'ensemble de mes omologues européens
dont une majorité était important de se
demander pourquoi est-ce qu'on
réunissait en urgence les ministres du
Conseil de du Conseil de l'Europe cont
tenu qu'il n'y avait pas d'épidémie en
Europe je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement le niveau d'alerte
était important en France comparé à
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de voisins
qui nous entourent ça c'est pour la
partie qui ne me concerne pas mais c'est
je tiens à le
dire sur
l'orientation l'orientation par le SAMU
vers le SAMU plutôt que vers la médecine
de ville et bien écoutez la doctrine
initiale était dès qu'on identifie ou
dès qu'on suspecte un malade potentiel
du coronavirus on doit l'isoler on doit
l'isoler il n'y a pas encore d'épidémie
galopante dans le pays en tout cas on ne
le sait
pas et donc il est important fondamental
de casser toute chaîne de contamination
avant même qu'elle se développe et donc
le passage par le SAMU était le moyen
dès lors qu'il y avait une suspicion une
confirmation de cas d'isoler les
personnes en milieu hospitalier c'est ce
qui a été fait à contamine monjois c'est
ce qui a été fait avec le rapatriment
des expatriés de Wuhan c'est ce qui a
été fait systématiquement dans toute ce
qu'on appelait la première phase
empêcher le virus d'entrer et l'empêcher
de se
transmettre l'adresser ces patients là
en médecine de ville ça comportait
plusieurs risques un que vous avez
vous-même soulevé dans une salle
d'attente si quelqu'un sans protection
qui a une suspicion de covid vient pour
consulter son médecin il peut contaminer
d'autres personnes et il peut contaminer
son
médecin par ailleurs les outils de
mesure n'étaient pas aussi optimum en
médecine de ville et et c'est tout à
fait normal que si c'était à l'hôpital
il n'a jamais était question d'écarter
les médecins du dispositif d'ailleurs il
était prévu et convenu que si l'épidémie
commençait à diffuser à l'instar de ce
qu'on fait dans les épidémies grippales
il ce serait on passerait à un
diagnostic clinique des cas
symptômatiques réalisés par des médecins
en médecine de ville vous me posez la
question de de la suite ensuite nous
avons décidé d'hospitaliser les patients
que si c'était nécessaire lorsque le
virus a diffusé qu'on était passé à un
stade ultérieur de diffusion du virus
qu'on était plus en train d'empêcher le
virus d'entrer mais qu'on voulait
limiter sa sa propagation étit
hospitalisés les cas sévères les autres
cas étaient adressés en isolement chez
eux ou en structure autolière lorsqu'il
n'était pas en capacité de s'isoler
correctement chez eux dès lors nous
sommes rentrés dans ce qu'on applique
depuis des dizaines d'années dans notre
pays c'est-à-dire le diagnostic clinique
syndromique avec des réseaux de médecins
sentinels qui font remonter les données
et tout cas symptomatique évoquant un
covid a été considéré comme covid
jusqu'à preuve du contraire dès lors
tout cas symptommatique qu'on considérit
comme un risque de covid se voyer isoler
le temps
nécessaire vous me posez aujourd'hui la
question de la médecine de ville la
médecine de ville elle a un rôle
centrale la médecine a un rôle un rôle
central elle va avoir un rôle encore
plus important alors que les rhumes les
ryinovaringites les angines la grippe
vont arriver dans notre pays ils vont
nécessiter de faire la part des choses
entre ce qui relèverait du covid et ce
qui relèverait de tout autre virus hélas
Friant de la période automnale et
hivernale donc la médecine de ville a
toute sa place je trava travaille
d'ailleurs avec les syndicats et et
l'ordre professionnel pour pour
anticiper avec eux quel rôle pourrait
être le leur notamment en matière de
diagnostique pour cela il me manque des
éléments factuels avant de pouvoir vous
répondre notamment j'ai saisi la Haute
Autorité de Santé sur la place des
médecins généralistes dans le diagnostic
clinique des personnes symptômatique
j'aurai la réponse j'aurai la réponse
prochainement mais sans attendre j'ai
fait aussi le choix madame la sénatrice
de développer la télémédecine et de
manière inédite dans notre pays je crois
que nous réalisions quelques dizaines de
milliers d'actes de télémédecine par an
dans notre pays à 1 million d'actes de
télémédecine par semaine à cela
plusieurs raisons j'ai décidé nous avons
décidé de faire prendre en charge à 100
% les consultations de télémédecine de
simplifier par tous les moyens y compris
par des moyens qui jusqu'ici n'étaient
pas autorisés comme Skype comme WhatsApp
même autoriser les consultations
téléphoniques même autoriser la
téléconsultation pour les infirmières
pour les kinés et ça a permis au
médecins sans s'exposer sans exposer les
autres malades de participer grandement
à la prise en charge des malades à la
phase épidémique cette télémédecine se
poursuit j'ai fait le choix de continuer
avec les mesures d'exception pour ne pas
faire s'effondrer la télémédecine pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée en avril 11
% des consultations se sont faites en
télémédecine alors même jusqu'à 55 %
pour l'activité des des endocrinologues
ou 48 % pour l'activité des pneumologues
donc on a massivement développé ça vous
me posez ensuite la question des données
scientifiques je vais pas vous faire ici
le tour sauf si vous le souhaitez de
l'ensemble
des acteurs scientifiques qui éclairent
les décisions et l'organisation de
l'État sachez que les données
scientifiques elles sont d'autant plus
simples à suivre lorsqu'elles sont
corroborées par plusieurs organismes
nationaux et internationaux en
l'occurrence il y a eu un certain
consensus entre l'OMS le CDC au niveau
européen le Conseil des ministres
européens de la santé le conseil
scientifique qui a été mis en place la
Direction générale de la santé qui est
le bras armé de la politique de santé
publique et de sécurité sanitaire du
ministère les autorités de santé
centralisé et décentralisé le Haut
conseil de santé publique la Haute
Autorité de Santé les agences régionales
de santé les organismes de recherche
comme l'inerme l'Institut Pasteur tous
ces acteurs sont venus éclairer les
décisions éclairer les doctrines les
changer par endroit l'Académie de
médecine a joué aussi un rôle en cela et
on a pu avoir des doctrines qui ont
évolué au fur et à mesure que les
connaissances évoluaient je trouve ça
assez sain que nous puissions adapter
les doctrines et les stratégies au fur
et à mesure que les connaissances
scientifiques s'affinent et puis nous
disposons en outil de pilotage d'une
batterie d'indicateurs très importante
j'en ai présenté un certain nombre hier
l'incidence incidence des personnes
âgées le taux de positivité des tests la
saturation des RA le r d'admission aux
urgences le r d'appel à SOS médecin et
cetera et cetera sur le plan hospitalier
moi je n'ai aucun regret madame la
sénatrice mais alors aucun regret
d'avoir anticipé le plan blanc
généralisé à l'échelle du pays et je me
souviens que les premiers jours
effectivement j'avais remonté
d'établissement de santé public ou privé
me disant mais vous nous empêchez
d'opérer les malades alors que on n pas
covid la particularité d'une épidémie
avec un virus aussi contagieux et aussi
invasif que le coronavirus c'est que ça
va très vite ça va très vite et quand ça
monte ça monte très vite si nous prenons
par exemple des mesure importante à
Marseille et en région PACA c'est parce
que ça va très vite à Marseille et en
PACA nous sommes à plus de 30 % de taux
de saturation des RA par des patients
covid j'ai présenté hier l'évolution des
chiffres sur des régions comme la région
aura ou la région Île-de-France et on
peut se souvenir queà l'automne au
printemps dernier pardon et à l'automne
dernier l'hiver dernier au printemps
dernier c'est c'est monté très vite
plusieurs centaines de réanimations
chaque
jour plusieurs centaines de réanimation
chaque jour lorsque vous êtes dans une
situation où les réanimations sont
occupées par de la chirurgie programmée
et que vous avez peu de place devant
vous vous mettez en danger des centaines
des milliers de vies nous avons sauvé
des centaines et des milliers de vies en
activant un plan blanc anticipé en
vidant les réanimations en amont parce
que nous n'aurions pas pu le faire si la
vague vu la vitesse qu'elle avait au
printemps dernier nous avait pris de
cours donc les établissements ont tous
particip et nous avons augmenté de façon
quand je dis on c'est l'ensemble des
territoires des soignants des agences
qui ont augmenté les lidrea pour faire
face à la bague et encore une fois les
hôpitaux et les réanimations ont tenu
aujourd'hui la situation est différente
madamerice puisque un nous avons des
indicates plus fin de meilleur
connaissance du virus nous avons des
modélisations sur lesquelles nousous
desquelles nous nous inspirons que j'ai
présenté hier l'Institut Pasteur
notamment qui permettent d'appréhender
semaine après semaine l'évolution du
nombre de réat et donc nous avons mis en
place des indicateurs par territoire
voire par hôpital pour donner à chacun
ses propres outils de gestion et lorsque
ça devient nécessaire un hôpital se voit
contraint d'annuler des opérations de
vider des blocs opératoires de les
transformer en salle de réanimation du
personnel a été formé les expériences de
la gestion de crise ont été partagées
pour P pouvoir faire face à cette crise
épidémique et l'autre choix que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est de ne
pas annuler toutes les chirurgies
programmées parce que beaucoup de
malades ont retardé leur opération une
dame qui doit se pososer une prothèse de
hanche parce qu'elle souffre le martyre
et qui se voit différer de 6 mois son
opération ne peut pas supporter qu'on a
qu'on la diffère encore de 3 mois un
patient qui doit être greffé doit
pouvoir être greffé au moment venu donc
nous faisons nous jouons
aujourd'hui pas nous jouons mais en tout
cas nous nous travaillons à partir des
différents indicateurs pour annuler le
moins de de choses possibles que vous
dire d'autre par rapport à votre
question ben c'est tout je crois que
j'ai répondu à l'ensemble de vos
questions sinon vous me direz je je
complèter sur le retour le retour
d'expérience euh la question je vous la
pose c'est parce que
euh comment les médecins généralistes
actuellement sont informés euh de la
conduite à denenir alors ils le font
hein parce qu'entre eux ils se ils
fonctionnent ils ont une habitude mais
mais est-ce qu'il y a des des
préconisations des recommandations qui
ont été données et si oui par qui on
parle de sociétés savantes des sites des
collèges et autres mais est-ce qu'il y a
des des données pratiques un médecin
généraliste tout seul dans son cabinet
est-ce qu'il a une vraie procédure qui
lui a été mise en place et puis ma
question elle portait sur ce retour
d'expérience notamment puisqu'on voit
maintenant que le virus est un peu
partout euh dans des hôpitaux qui sont
pas forcément à la pointe comme on a pu
être au début avec les les hôpitaux du
Grand Est les hôpitaux parisiens ou échu
euh pareil quel est le degré
d'information des des médecins qui
reçoivent des patients covid dans les
hôpitaux généraux euh dans certains
départements sur quand on nous a dit il
y a un cluster dans l'avyon Comment les
les centres hospitaliers de de laavyon
ont eu parce que ce qui est important
c'est qu'il y ait pas de perte de temps
à essayer de mettre en place une prise
en charge alors que c'est déjà été fait
et que l'Île-de-France par exemple avait
tiré parti très vite de l'expérience des
euh du grand S et puis pour compléter
avant de vous c'estit la parole vous
n'avez pas répondu sur la qualité des
données de
l'OMS qu'avait posé euh ouais parce on a
posé la question hier à Madame à à
Madame Busin aussi sur
l' sachez qu'il y a un outil de
communication qui fonctionne très bien
qui s'appelle le DGS urgent qui est un
bulletin d'information extrêmement
complet parfois on a pu nous dire qu'il
était trop et parfois nous avons fait
plus synthétique pour nous assurer que
cha
appréhender le bon niveau d'information
il y a 800000 abonnés qui sont des
professionnels de santé parmi lesquels
évidemment les médecins hospitaliers et
libéraux ces bulletins ont été envoyés
de manière extrêmement régulière par
ailleurs il y a eu de nombreux échanges
et il y a toujours de nombreux échanges
avec les syndicats les sociétés savantes
les ordres professionnels tous les
protocoles de prise en charge des
patients covid ont été travaillés avec
les sociétés savantes le collège de la
médecine générale et des fiches pratiqu
donc ont été diffusés après chaque
concertation les ordres professionnels
les syndicats ont eu des échanges
hebdomadaires systématique et organisé
avec les services du ministère ont été
régulièrement en contact avec mon
cabinet et y compris d'ailleurs avec moi
ils ont mon téléphone et on s'appelle
j'ai encore appelé le président du
syndicat mG France je crois que c'était
je l'ai embêté je sais plus c'était
samedi ou dimanche matin pour discuter
avec lui des perspectives d'évolution de
la place des généralistes dans le
diagnostic et faisant aussi le constat
je vous donne un exemple mais c'est très
concret je l'ai appelé Jacques baptistei
en lui disant je fais le constat que il
n'y a plus que 15 % aujourd'hui du
contact tracing qui est fait par les
médecins généralistes est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on repasse un message aux patients
quand ils sont diagnostiqués positifs
pour qu'ils ait ce réflexe d'appeler
leur médecin il m'a dit oui je l'ai
annoncé hier en rappelant à l'ensemble
des Français que lorsqu qu'ils ont un
test positif il ne faut pas qu'ils
hésitent à appeler leur médecins par
télémédecine par téléphone pas forcément
en allant le voir pour qu'ils puissent
les éclairer les orienter préparer leur
mise à l'abri et leur donner tout
conseil utile voir assurer la
surveillance les médecins ont toutes
leur place dans le dispositif donc c'est
un exemple monsieur le ministre nous
avons reçu ce matin même un médecin
généraliste il nous le disait
qu'effectivement il avait contact à ça
mais le médecin généraliste ne peut pas
rentrer directement les cas contact
qu'il connaît par rapport à la
plateforme puisque c'est la CPAM qui
elle fait les plans contact vous voyez
ce sont des choses pratiques comme ça
qu'on essaie de tirer d'expérience parce
que les médecins le savent bien il y en
a ici dans cette assemblée qui sont
sénateurs qui continuent à exercer leur
profession qu' on véritablement le
contact direct avec la population c'est
quelque chose de simple vous voyez c'est
c'est un petit peu là-dedans que l'on
essaie de
d'avancerci pardonnez-moi de vous avoir
vous les médecins généralist sont
totalement accès à M
pro peuvent pas entrer directement ils
connaissent les patients ils peuvent pas
entrer directement en disant voz telle
telle personne on gagnerait du temps par
rapport à la CPAM c'est la CPM qui leur
dit un certain nombre de données après
avoir pris contact avec le malade alors
que ces données ils les ont parce que
eux sont en contact avec le malade voyez
il y a process ce qui ce qui nous a été
dit c'est que quand le Lab quand le Lab
le test est positif le lab atoire rentre
dans l'application CPAM le taux positif
et et que ne peuvent plus après y
rentrer de façon postérieure pour par
exemple y mettre les les membres de la
famille et autres donc ça ils ne peuvent
pas le faire d'accord c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose pardon les médecins
les médecins libéraux et les médecins
hospitaliers sont chargés de ce qu'on
appelle le tracing de niveau 1 c'est le
premier volet c'est le premier volet
d'ailleurs 65 % du contact tracing au
début de l'été était fait par les
médecins comme quoi c'est faisable les
2/3 des patients tracés l'été par les
médecins ça a chuté pendant l'été les
médecins ont accès à MPR ils ont accès à
contact covid qui leur permet de rentrer
données la question de modifier des
données dans un dispositif qui a
entériné le traçage des cas contact est
une question plus complexe qui passe par
amé pro puisque c'est alors l'assurance
maladie qui prend le relais vous avez
ces trois niveaux hein le niveau 1 c'est
les médecins de terrain niveau 2 c'est
l'assurance maladie et pour les clusters
et les cas complexes c'est l'agence
régionale de santé qui s'en occupe
maintenant je suis tout à fait disposé à
appeler le médecin en pratique vous
savez en fait dans dans mon quotidien
dans mon exercice de ministre je
surprends parfois les gens en les
appelant avec mon téléphone assez
spontanément quand j'entends qu'il y a
des difficultés qui sont au jour pour
qu'il m'expliquent et qu'on partage et
parfois ils ont raison parfois c'est
nous mais peu importe qui a raison la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
avance donc je regarderai et je demande
à mon cabinet de de vérifier ce point en
particulier
euh je vous ai répondu du coup oui sur
la question des données de l'OMS écoutez
les données de l'OMS hein moi je ne suis
pas chargé de l'évaluation de l'OMS il y
a une mission d'évaluation qui a été
initiée de l'OMS je me suis rendu au
siège de l'OMS à la rencontre du docteur
tedros ainsi que mon collègue et
homologue le ministre allemand de la
santé yens span pour rappeler notre
soutien à la structure parce qu'on a
besoin de l'OMS on a besoin d'une
autorité et d'une organisation mondiale
comme l'OMS mais il faut évidemment
faire un retour d'expérience sur la
façon dont les données ont été gérées
traitées les recommandations apportées
et c'est toute la lumière qui sera en
fait sur cette question c'est pas du
tout le moment de jeter le
discrédit sur une institution surtout
surtout sans fondement mais par contre
c'est vrai qu'elle a joué un rôle
important dans la crise puisquelle a
apporté une expertise elle avait un
regard international plus aigu que le
nôtre hein le regard sur la situation
chinoise et premièrees semaines il est
plus aisé de l'avir à travers une
institution mondiale qui partage les
données en transparence qu'en passant
des coups de téléphone à des amis
chinois donc l'OMS nous a été utile elle
a fait elle-même évoluer ses
recommandations mais quand j'en discute
quand on a discuté avec le docteur
tedros en disant mais là sur les tests
sur les masques vous avez fait évoluer
les doctrine il me regarde on est
médecins tous les deux on sait très bien
que les connaissances changent évolue
que la recherche a progressé et donc il
est normal qu'on fasse évoluer les
choses progressivement il aurait été
tout à fait possible si on prend la
question des masques par exemple mais
vous allez m'emmener sur cette question
j'ai pas envie de de déflorer le sujet
mais il aurait été tout à fait aussi
possible qu'on se que les que le
l'intuition en tout cas d'après les
données don scientifiques dont le MS
disposait qu'elle conclut qu'il n'y
avait pas de passage aérosol du
coronavirus et que donc le port du
masque ne s'imposait pas vous voyez donc
elle a été capable d'évoluer elle l'a
dit à chaque fois qu'elle a évolué nous
sommes inspirés entre autres de ces
recommandations nous les avons pas
toujours suivi parfois nous avons
anticipé un certain nombre de décisions
comme sur la question du port du
masque merci Sylvie
vermiller merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit que
nous étions là pour discuter des choix
qui ont été faits euh je pense que nous
sommes aussi là pour discuter des choix
que vous pourriez faire euh vu
l'expérience dont vous disposez
aujourd'hui euh j'aurais quatre
questions précises la première c'est
quel est le regard que vous portez sur
l'efficience ou l'inefficience de santé
publique
France
leur leur absence sur la gestion des des
des stocks
stratégiques du coup c'est ma ma deuxème
question la question des stocks
stratégiques quelle assurance quelle
garantie pouvez-vous nous donner
aujourd'hui sur le niveau des stocks
stratégiques en médicaments en
équipement de protection individuelle et
puis quelle est votre position dès
aujourd'hui euh quant aux vaccins qui
sont annoncés euh même si ce sont des
vaccins imp partiels annoncés pour la
fin de l'année ou premier trimestre 2021
comment est-ce que vous vous assurer que
nous pourrons euh que les Français
pourront en disposer euh autant que de
besoin
trè question avec la reprise d'épidémie
est-ce que vous veillez aujourd'hui à
l'intégration du privé parmi le public
avec le public est-ce que vous veillez à
cette synergie on a pu voir au cours de
nos auditions que alors que des hôpitaux
publics étaient saturés il existaient
des cliniques vides et est-ce que vous
vous avez pris les moyens de de remédier
à cela et 4è question euh avec
l'expérience qui est la votre dans cette
gestion de crise est-ce que vous
imaginez reconsidérer le rôle et les
moyens des hôpitaux de
proximité
merci alors je compte cinq questions
madame la sénatrice d'abord le regard
que je peux porter sur l'efficience de
santé publique France santé publique
France a été au rendez-vous de
l'épidémiologie a été au rendez-vous de
la distribution santé publique France a
était percuté par sa première grande
crise sanitaire d'envergure affectant le
territoire français et la population
française dans son ensemble je vais pas
vous faire ici le le rappel de
l'intégration de l'prus dans un
dispositif rénové qui était santé
publique France je crois que l'ensemble
ou presque l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale dans cette
enceinte en fonction lorsque la loi a
était présentée a voté cette intégration
qui faisait plutôt sens mais que je ne
me prive pas de réinterroger pour
l'avenir
santé publique France est est une agence
structurée avec beaucoup de
scientifiques qui produisent beaucoup de
données qui sont précieuses au
quotidien et qui s'est retrouvé en plus
de cela d'une mission logistique qu'elle
assure avec le stock avec les gestion
mais avec une mission de distribution
dans l'urgence il a fallu à partir d'un
seul entrepô national à Marol organiser
la distribution dans chaque hôpital dans
chaque officine de masque de production
dans
l'urgence
ça aussi ça peut réinterroger la façon
demain de stocker les matériaux de
protection est-ce qu' est-ce qu'un seul
stock
centralisé doit être la solution mon
avis mon sentiment personnel je nai pas
mes sentiments ici mais pour avoir passé
énormément de temps de coup de fil nuit
et jour pour essayer de comprendre
comment faire sortir les camions d'un
entrepôt pour aller arroser l'ensemble
du territoire où les gens attendaient
légitimement des masques je je je pense
qu'on fera différemment mais d'ailleurs
votre commission d'enquête a aussi pour
pour but de nous éclairer et éclairer
les décisions je l'ai annoncé très tôt
au Parlement je souhaitais m'appuyer sur
les travaux des parlementaires à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat pour
dessiner le système de demain les stocks
stratégiques madame la sénatrice je ne
voudrais pas vous dire de bêtises dans
les chiffres mais sur les médicaments on
a annoncé qu'on avait reconstitué des
stocks notamment de médicaments à usage
de d'anesthésie réanimation de manière à
être capable de traiter jusqu'à 29000
malades alors pas 29000 malades en même
temps nous n'aurions pas les lit pour
cela mais jusqu'à 29 malades là où nous
avons accueilli au total dans la
première vague 17000 malades c'est
important et ces stocks de médicaments
stratégiques en en réanimation
anesthésie on l'avait dit avec Édouard
Philippe Premier ministre de l'époque
c'était un point de tension crucial nous
ne sommes jamais tombé à zéro mais alors
il a fallu déployer des trésors de
d'ingéniosité de la sur le territoire
pour pouvoir basculer des petits stocks
dormants de certains hôpitaux cliniques
vers d'autres hôpitaux qui risquaient
d'en manquer le fait est que aucun
malade n'a été extubé faute de pouvoir
le maintenir en C artificiel par les
médicaments à dooc mais c'est pas
forcément passé loin donc nous avons
pris la décision de reconstituer des
stocks plus importants beaucoup plus
importants que ceux dont nous disposions
surtout dans un contexte où la demande
mondiale explosait avec des
consommations parfois multiplié par 1000
par
1000 faut même savoir qu'il y a des pays
producteurs les principaux pays
producteurs qui se sont retrouvés à
manquer de ce type de médicament
lorsqu'ils ont été eux même confrontés à
la vague
épidémique et pour se fournir un
médicament dans la gestion en pleine
crise sanitaire j'ai passé un grand
nombre d' appel de qui relevait de la
diplomatie internationale pour obtenir
des envois et des arrivées
supplémentaires donc c'est étendu et
donc nous devons faire plus attention à
l'avenir et c'est pour ça que nous avons
un stock plus important sur les masques
nous l'avons dit hein nous voulons 1
milliard de masques de stock stratégique
d'État 800 millions de masques
chirurgicaux 200 millions de masques
FFP2 nous sommes quasiment arrivés à
reconstituer ce stock à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle ce sera le cas
dans la semaine ou les 15 jours qui
arrivent où il nous manque peut-être 100
millions de masques chirurgiqu ad dat et
nous avons quelques 60 millions de
masques FFP2 de plus que ce que prévoi
nos objectifs de stock stratégique nous
avons également des millions de masques
chirurgico pédiatrique et nous avons de
quoi équiper les liades réanimation pour
monter nos lid RA jusqu'à 14000 au prix
d'effort énorme hein mais nous serions
en état de le faire nous avons les
respirateurs les médicaments et les
matériels de protection pour ça sur le
vaccin alors je ne sais pas si je dois
vous donner ma position en tout cas la
position du ministre de la santé c'est
qu'un vaccin il sera proposé au français
quand il existera et quand il aura
démontré par les études cliniques
correctement réalisé en population
générale qu'il est à la fois efficass et
sûr comment est-ce que nous faisons pour
anticiper cela nous avons créé un
consortium de quatre pays avec les
Pays-Bas l'Italie l'Allemagne et la
France nous avons prospecté auprès d'un
laboratoire qui était le premier
laboratoire à je cro en tout cas l'un
des tout premier à envisager une phase 3
c'est-à-dire les phases
d'expérimentation du vaccin en
population générale un laboratoire
anglais du nom d'AstraZeneca avec un
projet de recherche développé par
l'Université d'Oxford recherche publique
nous avons travaillé avec ce laboratoire
et nous avons fait un contrat
d'intention de commande de 300 de 300
millions de doses de ces vaccins alors
jusqu'à négocier d'ailleurs le prix il
est pas cher en l'occurrence euh pour le
jour où si ce vaccin s'avérait sûr et
efficace nous puissions en disposer pour
tout le territoire européen et la France
peut se targuer à la demande du
Président de la République d'avoir à
chaque fois
systématiquement organisé les choses
pour que nous disposions de dos
supplémentaires afin d'aider des pays
qui sont en difficulté pour pouvoir s'en
procurer par la suite la Commission
européenne nous avons proposé la
Commission européenne de reprendre le
flambeau nous lui avons confié ce
précontrat et la Commission européenne a
organisé des comités d'experts avec des
experts issus de nombreux pays dont la
France d'ailleurs qui se charge de
prospecter auprès de chacun des
laboratoires sérieux qui a une phase
avancée de développement de vaccin de
manière à ce que le premier qui trouve
un bon vaccin sûr et efficace on soit
sûr d'en avoir sans délai pour
l'ensemble de la population européenne
sur les recommandations d'usage de ce
vaccin antiovid et à qui il sera proposé
dans quelles conditions je ne peux pas
vous répondre ça va dépendre des données
d'études cliniques de ce vaccin il y
aura évidemment une saisine de la Haute
Autorité de Santé en urgence lorsque
nous aurons ces données sur le privé
parmi le
public j'ai évidemment lu la presse
Twitter et j'ai appelé beaucoup de
directeurs d'établissement lorsqu'on me
disait que tel établissement n'était pas
mobilisé dans le privé alors on chercher
des Lida je peux vous garantir que quand
vous êtes ministre de la santé que vous
passez vos jours et vos nuits à chercher
le moindre lid RA pour organiser des
transferts sanitaires que vous appelez
des ministres à l'étranger pour leur
demander s'ils ont des places pour vos
malades que vous montez des TGV en moins
de 48 heures ce qui n'avait jamais été
fait dans notre pays pour pouvoir
transporter des malade là où il y avait
de la place il faudrait pardon de
l'expression complètement abruti pour
considérer qu'il y aurait des places
dans les réas de l' de la clinique du
coin et ce serait pas
grave on est d'accord bon je crois crois
pas être complètement abruti et je crois
pas que les ARS soi complètement abrutis
et je ne pense pas que les médecins des
établissements soient complètement
abrutis s'il y a eu des retards parfois
à la mobilisation du secteur privé
systématiquement les agences de santé
dans les territoires ont été mobilisés
pour leur dire que ça devait cesser il y
a eu peut-être eu des situations dans
une région d'ù vous avez auditionné le
directeur général monsieur le
vice-président de la commission qui a pu
entraîner nécessité de ma part quelques
appels de sensibilisation et très vite
la situation rentré dans l'ordre et
j'ajoute que un moment où les cliniques
CER on me faisait encore remarquer que
des cliniques n'étaient pas mobilisées
suffisamment le président de la
Fédération Hospitalière privée monsieur
Lamine Garby peut-être que vous l'avez
auditionné publi des communiqués pour
dire que c'était factuellement faux et
que les cliniques était mobilisé donc je
vous le redis tout lit utile pour des
malades en réanimation ou pas en
réanimation en hôpital de proximité ou
en CHU en clinique privée ou à l'hôpital
public tout lit utile doit être utilisé
doit être doit-être et je vous le dis
nous n'avons pas manqué d'utiliser
l'ensemble des parcs hospitaliers j'ai
pas un regard dans chaque unité de
chaque hôpital vous le pensez bien mais
les directeurs généraux des ARS les
délégués départementaux long et je peux
vous dire que ils n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts pour évacuer des patients qui le
nécessitent vers d'autres pays parfois
et qu'avant de faire cela ils ont
évidemment il se sont évidemment assurés
que tous les lidreas sur le territoire
étaient monsieur le ministre vous parlez
d'une région que je connais bien je puis
vous dire qu'il y a eu des difficultés
au départ dans certaines régions ça a
été largement remonté et commenté
d'accord voilà parce que c'est la
réalité parce qu'on a été confronté
directement avec ça ça ne s'est pas
passé partout mais soyons lucide il faut
reconnaître qu'il y a des endroits où il
y a eu des difficultés point c'est pas
pour autant une critique c'est surtout
qu'il ne faut pas et c'était la question
de notre rapporteur recommencer donc
précisément y y a-t-il eu des mesures
pour faire en sorte que ça se fluidifie
encore mieux ces relations entre le
privé et le
public question oui
moi aussi j'avais j'avais appelé la mine
Garby au moment où où il y avait ces ces
articles qui euh qui qui apparaissait et
on l'a auditionné dans le cadre des
auditions rapporteurs que j'ai fait il y
a eu il y a eu pendant quelques jours
des points où il y a eu en effet une une
latence entre le moment où on a mobilisé
le le privé moi ce qui m'intéresserait
ce qui intéresserait pour notre
commission d'enquête c'est qu'on est un
peu justement ce traveling arrière en
disant tel tel hôpital tel clque pendant
2 3 jours on a eu qu'on puisse qu'on
puisse voir la réalité parce que on est
sur un témoignage d'un tel un élu qui
nous dit y dans mon département tel la
clinique n'a pas été mobilisée mais il
faut qu'on qu'on se base sur des des
choses vraiment factuelles donc si on
peut avoir un moment un panorama réel de
ce qui s'est passé la Fédération la FHP
peut nous le faire mais si on peut
croiser les données de la FHP les vôres
ce serait bien non mais attendez je vais
vous dire deux
choses un à un moment donné je me suis
dit est-ce que c'est une réalité appelé
les dgdars je leur ai mis le dgdars de
la région concernée j'ai mis un petit
peu de
pression deuxèmement j'ai dit très
clairement que avec les données PMSI
c'estàd les données informatiques
d'hospitalisation issu de
l'hospitalisation des patients tout
patient tout patient qui aurait été
opéré en chirurgie programmée puis
adressé dans un service de soins
intensif ou de réanimation d'une
clinique du territoire lors même que les
plans blancs étaient activés non
seulement ne donnerait pas lieu au
paiement des soins à l'établissement par
l'assurance maladie mais que je
m'occuperai personnellement d'établir un
dispositif de sanction donc j'ai été
extrêmement clair sur le sujet par
contre quand vous parlez de remonter et
de commentairire monsieur le sénateur
moi une fois j'ai été interpellé au
sujet d'une clinique qui avait me
disait-on si lit de réanimation en
appelant cette clinique le directeur m'a
dit oui j'ai si de réanimation mais je
ne peux pas prendre de malade covid
pourquoi parce qu'il faisait c'était des
lits qui faisaient partie de ce qu'on
appelle les lits non covid puisquon a
évidemment gardé des lits non covid dans
les hôpitaux si quelqu'un fait un AVC
très grave fait un infarctus ou si
quelqu'un se fait opérer d'un cancer
qu'il faut opérer dans l'urgence on va
pas lui dire désolé les lits sont
réservés pour les patients covid donc il
y avait des lits également dans le
secteur public qui étaient réservés pour
des patients non covid et autre et
d'autre part il m'a dit il y a une
clinique aussi dans sur le territoire
qui n'a pas forcément ses lit pleins
mais attention on lui a demandé de céder
ces médicaments de réanimation et
l'équipe d'ailleurs est venue renforcer
l'équipe hospitalière pour faire face à
l'augmentation des lits donc attention
enfin je veux dire moi je voudrais pas
qu'on qu'on qu'on laisse à penser deux
choses un qu'il y aurit des
professionnels de santé avec vocation
chevillé au corps qui aurait attendu le
chalent en voyant que tout s'effondrait
ou en tout cas tout menaait de
s'effondrer autour d'eux je ne crois pas
une seconde je ne crois pas une seconde
et deuxièmement je ne voudrais pas qu'on
laisse à penser que des directeurs de
structure de
territorial ce soit entre guillemets euh
désintéressé du sujet de la mobilisation
du parc hospitalier parce que j'ai vécu
la crise avec eux je peux dire qu'ils
ont vécu la crise avec moi et nous
étions parfaitement mobilisés donc
j'entends ce que vous dites comme
remarque nous aurons les données PMSI
qui nous permettront d'ailleurs
d'éclairer et si je vous le dis si un
établissement n'a pas été loyal dans
dans cette gestion de crise ce dont je
le dis je doute je rendrai volontiers
publi puisque j'en serai ça monsieur le
ministre il ne s'agit pas de ça il
s'agit
d'établissement qui avaient des
livides parce que ils étaient prêts à
attendre des malades covid et ils ne les
ont jamais vu venir voilà ce n'est
Paso mais tout à fait mais on vous les
donnera il y a aucun souci là-dessus
mais ce n'est pas une remise en cause ça
veut dire que c'est un problème de
fonctionnement d'articulation entre le
public et le privé ne faisons pas une
situation qui a été idylique il y a eu
quelques problèmes et c'est logique ces
problèmes-là et le but de notre
commission c'est pas de les dénoncer
c'est de faire en sorte que ça ne se
reproduise plus c'est la raison pour
laquelle la question de notre rapporteur
est
précise vous avez pris des mesures pour
que ça être bien sûr de la fluidité des
liens entre le public et le privé
j'ajoute deux choses si vous me
permettez après je je laisserai
volontier la parole dans les premières
semaines il fallait de l'ECMO pour faire
de la
réanimation que les réanimateur disait
qu'il fallait aussi un équipement en
ECMO c'estàd en circulation extra
cororporelle or beaucoup
d'établissements certains établissements
privés n'en étaient pas équipés ensuite
on a pu basculer et donc utiliser donc
attention il y a des gens qui n'ont pas
vu leur lit exploiter pour des raisons
médicales d'équipement et d'organisation
et lorsque les recommandation est évolué
ce que je veis vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur c'est que moi je suis prêt à
tout entendre parce que tout disfonction
ement doit être corrigé surtout vu la
période que nous sommes en train de
vivre ce que je demande c'est que
lorsqu'on m'interpelle sur des sujets
comme
celui-ci on soit également précis en
allant jusqu'à me donner les
établissements les dates les équipes à
partir de là je peux faire un travail de
rétex qui soit satisfaisant or
pardonnez-moi monsieur le sénateur c'est
pas du tout ne le prenez pas Madame la
la rapporteur pour pour vous mais quand
on me dit il y a eu des établissement
qui écoutez c'est formidable mais moi on
me dit qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'établissement qui donc été corrigé
monsieur
minist et là on progresse c'est ça a été
vite corrigé c'est pas la remise en
cause on va pas s'éterniser là-dessus ça
a été corrigé simplement il y a eu
besoin de facteur de correction ce qui
est légitime est-ce que dans tous les
endrois maintenant il y aura plus ce
type de problème simplement voilà c'est
pas de dénoncer quoi que ce soit c'est
pas voilà si vous avez pris des mesures
et ben s'il y en a eu écoutez bon on
peut pas remettre en cause les
témoignages qu'on a eu depuis des heures
et des heures d'audition nous nous
prenons Act de ces témoignages on peut
dire que tout s'est bien passé on a
constaté un nombre de morts qui était
quand même important en France par
rapport à d'autres pays donc on peut se
dire aussi qu'on peut peut-être encore
améliorer les choses mais je sais que
c'est votre volonté monsur pasutre
contzmoi aidez-moi en me donnant les
élément factuel tout à fait et on vous
aidera vous inquiétez
pas ah pardon sur les hôpitaux de
proximité le séure de la santé d'abord
la loi ma santé 2022 apporté une
ambition très forte pour les hôpitaux de
proximité puisque vous savez que nous
souhaitons y rétablir et nous avons
commencé à le faire des plateaux
technique de la biologie de l'imagerie
restaurer parfois de l'activité
l'activité d'urgence pour transformer et
continuer la modernisation de ces
hôpitaux qui a commencé d'ailleurs avec
Marisol Touren dans un mandat précédent
et qui avait donné un statut et un
financement péren à ces établissements
le sigure de la santé va plus loin et le
plan d'investissement d'ailleurs de 6
milliards d'euros plus la reprise de
dett permettront de compléter de
conforter cette modernisation pour
restaurer au cœur de l'ensemble des
territoires y compris les moins peuplés
des hôpitaux de Lig Deon pour accueillir
les
malades merci et votre regard sur santé
publique France vous nous avez donné des
des faits par rapport au stock à la
logistique à la distribution mais votre
regard sur santé publique France et
l'intégration de l' prus que l'on a voté
pour un grand nombre vous l'avez rappelé
est-ce que finalement c'est une bonne
chose ou est-ce que il y a quelques
modifications apportter par rapport à sa
réactivité en période de crise c'était
la question de Sylvie vermiller
l'organisation de santé publique France
dans les territoires à mon sens
mériterait d'être réinterrogé les
fameuses cires qui sont en lien avec les
ARS mais qui ne sont pas sous tutelle en
proprement parler ARS il faut intégrer
la recherche fondamentale la recherche
appliquée et la question logistique dans
un appareil qui soit pleinement
performant et qui pour ça dispose de
tous les outils donc dans les
territoires je pense qu'il est important
de de se reposer question et ça ira
d'ailleurs jusqu'au stock de matériel de
protection davantage territorialisé
qu'il l' aujourd'hui davantage
territorial je vous ai répondu sur ce
point-là et je vous ai dit les grandes
qualités de santé publique France pour
pouvoir fournir des données ce qui
fournissent d'ailleurs toujours
aujourd'hui avec je peux vous le dire
application en précisant certain nombre
de choses parfois ça a pu créer de la
confusion et j'ai pu être amené à le
dire je vous donne un exemple Canté
publicque France a été l'organe qui
comptabilisait et publiait le nombre de
tests réalisés dans notre pays avant que
nous ayons cidep
santé publique France publié sur son
site un nombre de tests fortement
sous-évalué par rapport à la réalité
semaine après semaine et indiquait
d'ailleurs sur son site que ce nombre de
tests était estimé sur la base
d'échantillon de laboratoire public et
privé d' public et privé donc plusieurs
fois j'ai appelé la président de santé
publ France en lui disant peut-être
qu'au lieu de publier des chiffres qui
sont sous évaluer parce queà l'époque on
me faisait reproche de ne pas tester que
les chiffres publiés tout était basé sur
ces chiffres là mais eux me disaient
vous savez on fait des études
statistiques on n'est pas en train de
dire qu'on est on n pas dans notre rôle
en colligeant la totalité des choses on
explique clairement sur no sites que ces
tests sont sous-évalués de fait puisque
nous les établissons à partir d'un
échantillon de laboratoire et pas de
façon exhaustive nous n'avions pas
d'outil de mesur et de comptabilité
supplémentaire donc nous avons eu
énormément d'échanges avec santé
publique France sur la question des
masques évidemment et d'autres questions
et je continue d'avoir des échanges avec
eux sur un certain nombre de choses
regardez mais on peut pas le on peut pas
leur demander de faire un travail qui
soit à la fois un travail de rendre
compte à un moment donné de la situation
et dans de modélisation d'étude
épidémiologique par anticipation un
exemple c'est lorsque vous voyez les
courbes qui sont publiées d'incidence et
que du fait des retards d'inscription de
certaines données dans le cidep et bien
on pourrait avoir faussement
l'impression qu'il y a des incidences
qui baissent et que la situation
s'améliore mais santé publique France
alerte là aussi dans son bulletin en
disant attention les données ne sont pas
consolidées il faut les regarder avec 4
ou 5 jours de recul pour avoir
véritablement l'incidence donc si vous
regardez les données brutes de SPF vous
dit et vous comparez la réalité vous
dites mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font et en
réalité ils font un travail qui est un
travail qui est sérieux sur la base des
données dont ils disposent bon est-ce
que on peut est-ce qu'on peut changer
les choses oui on changera des choses je
je vous le dis et notamment en matière
de de gestion de crise mais on change
pas les les choses en cours de route en
tout cas pas en profondeur parce qu'il
nous faut de la stabilité il nous faut
de la stabilité dans le moment mais
viendra l'heure de se poser les
questions et de proposer des
réorganisations de la modernisation
partout où ça fait partout où ça fait
sens croyez-moi merci
merci Bernard
jaumier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre donc vous nous avez
expliqué votre stratégie si si je l'ai
bien compris c'est de maintenir la
circulation du virus à un niveau tel que
l'ensemble des activités de soins usuel
puissent se poursuivre pour ne pas pas
de
nouveau avoir cet effet collatéral sur
des ruptures de chaînes de soins et donc
juste une précision pour être bien
claire euh ça passe par l'augmentation
si nécessaire euh des moyens
hospitaliers un reformatage et vous avez
cité donc le chiffre d'une progression
jusqu'à 14000 délit de réanimation donc
c'est juste pour être clair si j'ai mal
compris vous vous vous le reprendrez
mais sinon donc vous êtes dans cet état
là d'esprit maintenir cette circulation
de virus
avoir une marge supplémentaire pour
augmenter si besoin les moyens
hospitaliers les moyens de réanimation
et dans cette jusqu'à cette limite là le
fonctionnement usuel des hôpitaux ne
sera enfin sera impacté au minimum en
tout cas il y aura pas l'impact qu'il a
eu au printemps j'ai quelques questions
à vous poser la première est sur la
stratégie de lutte contre l'épidémie
avec euh on a vu se mettre en place donc
la stratégie sur les masques sur les
gestes barrières sur la distanciation
physique et qui paraît on va dire à peu
près abouti on peut toujours en discuter
des modalités et probablement d'ailleurs
relativement efficace puisque la reprise
de circulation du virus n'a pas du tout
la cinétique qu'elle avait au printemps
et puis le deuxième pilier qui est la
stratégie tester tracé isolé le Premier
ministre avait choisi protéger pour des
raisons politiques sans doute mais la
stratégie scientifique c'est tester
tracé isolé euh et cette stratégie là le
constat est largement partagé et
documenté qu'elle est
dysfonctionnelle donc je vais pas
reprendre l'ensemble des données nous
avons eu des auditions ces jours
derniers sur la question des tests des
délais pour accomplir les tests qui
souvent ont dépassé et depuis plusieurs
semaines le délai de contagiosité donc
qui impacté la capacité du test à
permettent une rupture des chaînes de
transmission c'est donné confirmé par la
CNAM qui lors des traçages se rend
compte que 80 % des personnes testées
positives n'avaient pas été identifié
comme cas contact donc beaucoup de
chaînes de transmission échappent
euh à cette stratégie et dans le volet
isolement un discours qui est parfois
difficile à comprendre mais bon parce
qu'il a beaucoup bougé aussi au au fur
et à mesure des connaissances hein je
notamment hein sur les durées
d'isolement mais qui à l'échelon
individuel on va dire est porté enverss
l'opinion publique mais pour les
personnes qui sont en habitat collectif
et communautaire une absence de solution
qui est proposée et donc toute cette
stratégie euh sur laquelle vous
travaillez actuellement euh son côté
dysfonctionnel et probablement pour une
large part responsable de la reprise de
circulation du virus comment est- on
arrivés là alors qu'il n'y a plus de
problème quantitatif en terme de test il
faut saluer cette action là et que cette
stratégie est bien établie depuis
plusieurs mois et que la période
estivale aurait pu permettre de
l'affiner et de la mettre en œuvre pour
éviter ces
reprises question suivante il m'en reste
deux nous avons
euh quand nous avons auditionné aussi
Benia
elle elle nous rappelait le constat
qu'elle avait fait quand elle était
membre du gouvernement de que la demande
de la société et c'est essentiel ce que
la façon dont se comporte une société
quand une épidémie survient était une
demande de transparence et
d'horizontalité hier vous avez annoncé
des décisions et on a constaté que les
élus des territoires concerné semblaient
n'avoir pas été concerté les acteurs
locaux de ces territoire les acteurs de
santé les élus
locaux les acteurs du système
médico-social pourquoi n'ont pas a-il
été consulté en amont de l'annonce de
ces décisions comment est-ce que
actuellement ces concepts
d'horizontalité et de transparence sont
mis en œuvre dans la façon dont vous
élaborez vos décisions et pour être
encore plus précis au cours de des
auditions beaucoup ont mis en avant le
rôle du couple préfémère on a tout de
même un peu le sentiment que là c'est le
préfet qui donne les ordres au maire et
il y a un troisième membre dans le
couple c'est le ministre qui donne les
instructions au-dessus et ça ça n'est il
y a quelque chose qui n'est pas
compréhensible qui provoque beaucoup de
révolte beaucoup de colère et qui risque
d'impacter parce que c'est ça le vrai
problème on en a discuté au cours de nos
auditions avec un certain nombre
interlocuteur si les réponses
autoritaires étaient les plus efficaces
du monde ma foi on est une démocratie
malgré tout mais euh peut-être certains
accepteraient de d'entendre ce ce
discours là mais il y a un risque fort
que ça impacte l'efficacité des des
décisions qui ont été annoncées et ça me
permet d'en venir à ma dernière question
qui est la question du lien de confiance
qui est
essentiel je crois qu'on a tous été très
marqué lors de nos auditions notamment
du mois de juillet où nous avons
auditionné ceux qu'on appelle les
acteurs de première
ligne du fait que leur discours était un
discours de colère de colère et de
ressentiment vis-à-vis des autorités
publiques et pourquoi c'est marquant
parce que j'allais dire et je voudrais
que mes propos je ne soi pas mal
interprétés mais ce sont des acteurs qui
sont des acteurs qui sont parfaitement
insérés dans notre société des ce ne
sont pas des personnes person qui vivent
mal l'insertion dans notre société et
qui légitimement ont un discours
vis-à-vis des institutions comme on peut
le voir qui est systématiquement de
rejet nous avons entendu des pharmaciens
des médecins des infirmières des aides à
domicile des professionnels du grand âge
et cetera tous nous dire qu'on ne les
avait pas respecté et qu'on les avait
pas respectés notamment parce que au
moment où ils étaient vivaient des
penurines matérielles les autorités ne
reconnaissez pas ne prononcez jamais ce
mot de pénurie et la la la distension de
ce lien de confiance est souvent cette
rupture est extrêmement
préjudiciable préjudiciable à la façon
dont notre pays peut faire face à
l'épidémie donc monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous vivez la rupture de ce
lien de confiance est-ce que pour vous
c'est un élément de préoccupation ce
dont je ne doute pas par ailleurs mais
comment
comment comptez-vous répondre à cette
rupture quel mot comptez-vous prononcer
à quelle valeur allez-vous vous référer
pour que dans notre pays les
institutions en charge de la santé les
autorités politique et l'ensemble de la
société ensemble marche et fasse bloc
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
j'aimerais commencer presque par
répondre à votre dernière question
monsieur jaumier mais je vais les
prendre dans l'ordre si vous êtes
d'accord l'augmentation des moyens
hospitaliers je vous confirme ce que
j'ai dit nous sommes en mesure
d'augmenter si la situation était
nécessaire l'équipement en ligne soins
critique réanimation à 14000 pour
pouvoir accueillir beaucoup de malades
au pris d'efforts considérables de
déprogrammation massives de
transformation de bloc opératoir de
salle de réveil en salle de réanimation
nous avons les respirateurs nous avons
les médicaments le personnel soignant
est fatigué mais il est toujours
mobilisé lorsqu'on a besoin de lui parce
qu'il a une vocation ont chevillé au
corps et c'est ce qui d'ailleurs fait
l'honneur des soignants dans notre pays
la stratégie n'est pas de maintenir une
circulation du virus hein monsieur le
sénateur la stratégie est d'enrayer la
circulation du virus d'écraser la
circulation du virus je parlais cet été
de traquer le virus plutôt que ce soit
lui qui nous traque traquer le virus
l'affaiblir le plus possible le mettre
au niveau le plus bas possible nous
avons réussi à le faire avec des mesures
extrêmement fortes dans une situation
qui échappait à toute autre modalité de
de gestion en sortie du du confinement
par contre la stratégie de de réponse et
ce qu'on appelle les mesures de gestion
ce fameux pilier 3 comme les
restrictions de circulation les grands
les diminutions des pas les restrictions
de circulation les restrictions de
rassemblement des grands rassemblements
jusqu'à des mesures qui peuvent toucher
les bars voir les restaurants et des
mesures qui sont douloureuses très
douloureuses pour pour notre pays pour
les gens qui travaillent dans C dans ces
secteurs et pour les gens qui aiment les
fréquenter ces décision là elles sont
fondées sur le strict niveau de pression
sanitaire d'ailleurs nous avons mis en
place des indicateurs j'en ai parlé 30 %
de patients covid en réanimation c'est
une alerte sérieuse qui fait basculer un
territoire 60 % en tout cas en fonction
de la situation territoriale est une
autre alerte sérieuse qui peut engendrer
encore d'autres types de décision la
pression sanitaire nous n'avons jamais
opéré desune gestion sur la base de
chiffres de courbees mais sur la base
d'une pression sanitaire alors la
pression sanitaire étant le reflet de
l'évolution de l'incidence notamment
chez les personnes âgées et vous
imaginez que c'est l'indicateur que nous
suivons pour pouvoir opérer quand vous
dites que le tracé tester tracé protégé
et dysfonctionnel je je je n'ai pas dit
autre chose que le fait que nous avions
nous rencontrions des difficultés
importantes pour assurer aux Français
qui nécessitent et qui sont publ
prioritaires l'accès au test dans les
bons délis vous l'avez souligné je vous
en remercie nous sommes montés même plus
à 1200000 mais à 1300000 tests par
semaine ce sont les
que j'avais hier grâce à la mobilisation
extraordinaire de l'ensemble des
laboratoires publics et privés qui
continue d'acheter des machines pour
faire de la PCR qui continue de
commander les machines avec une tension
mondiale très forte donc les
machinesarrivent arrivent encore au comp
de goutte mais on va continuer les
laboratoires s'apprêtent à faire encore
davantage de tests demain davantage ce
que j'ai dit cet été souvenez-vous cet
été je disais aux gens si vous devez
vous faire tester n'hésitez pas à aller
vous faire tester on est de on a de quoi
faire à l'époque on me disait vous avez
dit Monsieur le Ministre qu'on ferait
700000 tests on en fait que 4 100000
j'ai dis mais on est capable d'en faire
700000 mais aujourd'hui le virus circule
peu les gens ont peu de symptômes on est
au cœur de l'été et j'ai prévenu
d'ailleurs en conférence de presse avec
le premier ministre Jean Castex à la fin
du mois d'août que les semaines de
rentrée
est sans doute s'accompagné de tension
sur l'accès au test sans doute
s'acompagn parce que les gens rentr de
congé les gens rentrrai en entreprise où
on leur demandait de se faire tester
parfois de façon
d'ailleurs hors de de toute
justification mais c'est
ainsi et puis en plus la pression
sanitaire a commencé à monter et si vous
faites le calcul avec moi vous avez
aujourd'hui on on connaî on a des
données sur 80 % des gens qui se font
tester c'est le niveau de satisfaction
de remplissage du cidep sur ces 80 % on
sait déjà qu'il y a 28 % de patients
symptômatiques ils n'ont pas tous le
covid mais ils viennent avec des
symptômes ou en tout cas ils disent
venir avec des symptômes ce veut dire
rapporter à 100 % ça fait à peu près
déjà un/3 quand vous avez un diagnostic
vous avez deux à trois cas contact ça
veut dire que chaque jour vous avez à
peu près 35000 40000 cas contacts qui se
font tester vous ajoutelez à cela une
bonne dizaine de milliers de soignants
des aides à domicile et donc vous
arrivez déjà à un nombre conséquent et
en fait plus la pression sanitaire monte
plus le nombre de gens positifs et cas
contact monte plus le public prioritaire
augmentent donc face à cela la
priorisation qui avait été demandée au
début du mois d'août a fonctionner
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ne fonctionne plus et
c'est allé très vite et croyez-moi je le
déplore c'est pourquoi nous travaillons
sans relâche avec les agences de santé
avec les préfecture avec les
laboratoires et donc j'ai présenté les
des dispositions qui sont des
dispositions efficaces pour pouvoir
permettre à chacun lorsqu'il le justifie
par son état de santé de bénéficier du
test sans délai c'est le cas des barnom
en Île-de-France c'est 20 barnom qui
seront capables de faire chacun 500
tests par jour entre 8h et 14h ils sont
réservés au strict public prioritaire et
les laboratoires s'engagent à avoir un
rendu de résultats dans les 24 48 he je
l'ai dit hier soir aussi en toute
transparence devant les Français j'ai
rien à cacher monsieur le sénateur et du
coup j'ai pas grandchose à vous
apprendre que vous ne sachiez
déjà c'est que les 2/ers des tests
aujourd'hui sont rendus dans les 48
heures à l'échelle du pays mais là où ça
n'est pas le cas là où ce n'est pas le
cas notamment dans les métropoles et
notamment en île-de-fance c'est
problématique et c'est pour ça que nous
mettons le paquet pour réduire ces fil
d'attente est-ce que c'est ça qui est
responsable de la reprise épidémique je
ne le crois pas monsieur le sénateur je
ne crois pas ce n'est pas responsable de
la reprise épidémique des pays qui ont
mis en place un testé tracé isolé port
du masque systématique chez tout le
monde avec une culture de ça qui date de
plusieurs années parce qu'ils ont connu
des grandes pandémie ce sont pris des
vagues épidémiques y compris au moment
où il s'éend dé pas je pense par exemple
au Japon qui n'a jamais rencontré la
moindre difficulté ils sont structurés
comme ça dans leur système de santé
parce qu'ils ont fait face à des
épidémies que nous n'avons pas connu et
qui font qu'ils ont fort de leur
expérience était capable de bâtir un
système quasiment infaillible et malgré
ça ces pays-là ont été percutés d'autres
pays on m'a cité je crois ici dans le
Sénat déjà le cas d'Israël qui était un
exemple de pays qui était capable de
faire face aux choses très bien mais
Israël à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle est totalement confiné totalement
confiné l'Allemagne que vous citez
régulièrement comme un exemple et vous
avez sans doute raison de le faire
l'Allemagne a été la la première le
premier pays européen à reconfiner des
régions entières lorsque alors même que
le virus circulait très peu en réalité
le virus il a des zone d'activité aigu
avec des périodes épidémiques plus ou
moins intenses nous travaillons pour
qu'elle soit de moins le moins intense
possible avec le moins d'impact
sanitaire et des période d'acalmie où
les gens sont plus vigilants moi j'ai
passé mon mois d'oût monsieur le
sénateur pouvez pas dire autre chose
passé mon mois d'août aller dans tous
les territoires à faire des des alertes
quasi quotidiennes aux Français en leur
disant qu'on avait des signes de repris
épidémiqu dans les populations jeunes
notamment Marseille et je vais y venir
en disant attention parce que quand le
virus circule chez les jeunes l'exemple
international notamment en Floride et
ailleurs nous montre qu'il finit par
passer chez les moins jeunes et à
l'époque vous aviez des experts parmi
ceux que vous citez comme étant en
rupture de confiance avec nous qui sur
les plateaux télé disaient c'est
peut-être pas mal si les jeunes se
contaminent les uns les autres non mais
je ve dire il faut aussi se rendre
compte que un certain nombre d'experts y
compris que vous avez reçu je ne dis pas
que vous les avez reçu avec le tapis
rouge monsieur leateur je c'est pas du
tout ce que je dis c'est pas du tout ce
que je dis d'expert considéraent que le
virus avait muté pour être devenu moins
dangereux souvenez-vous de ce mois
d'août le virus a muté il est moins
dangereux les jeun ne se contaminent pas
ils font pas de forme grave il y aura
pas de deuxième vague et cetera et
cetera ce n'est pas le discours que j'ai
tenu jamais j'ai eu un discours d'alerte
de sensibilisation et je suis allé dans
les territoires dans lesquel le virus
circulait pour dire attention il faut
prendre maintenant les bonnes mesures il
faut prendre des mesures de gestion
parce que sinon le virus va repartir de
plus belle il va contaminer les
personnes fragiles et on aura un impact
sanitaire parce qu'il y a pas de raison
de penser qu'il est muté et c'est ainsi
que je viens au point suivant sur la
consultation et la concertation avec les
élus je vais vous donner deux éléments
de réponse d'abord je je considère qu'il
est fondamental d'avoir la confiance des
élus et de travailler avec eux parce que
c'est difficile quand vous êtes ma d'une
grande ville c'est très difficile et moi
je
vais je vais vous je vais remercier des
maires qui qui correspondent à
différents partis puis vous verrez avec
eux si c'est loupé vous vous
débrouillerez c'est pas je vais
remercier le maire de Montpellier
Michael de lafusse je vais remercier le
maire de Toulouse Jean-Luc moudin je
vais remercier la maire de Lille
particulièrement Martine au je vais oui
je vais remercier l'ensemble des maires
monsieur Gael perdriillot à
Saint-Étienne je vais remercier Madame
hiidalgo maire de Paris je vais
remercier Madame apéré maèire de Renn
l'ensemble de ces maires et bien
d'autres je les ai eu au téléphone hier
après-midi dans l'intervalle entre les
prises de décisions au Conseil de
défense et les annonces de décision du
Conseil de défense et et l'ensemble
l'ensemble l'ensemble s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît monsieur le ministre à
la parole l'ensemble de ces élus que
j'ai cité ont fait preuve d'une
réceptivité à l'égard et le maire de
écologiste de Grenoble Éric Piol et
d'autres encore l'ensemble des maire que
avec les qui j'ai pu discuter en
présentant les données épidémiologiques
et les mesures en leur annonçant qu'ils
auraient une une concertation avec le
préfet comme c'est la méthode pendant 48
he pour adapter pour adopter pour
adapter les mesures propre à chaque
territoire en fonction de la situation
épidémique je peux vous dire que je n'ai
pas eu de difficultés la situation
marseillaise c'est pas pour pointer du
doigt des élus mais j'ai eu c'est vrai
en fin d'après-midi le premier adjoint
maire de Marseille j'ai eu également le
président de la région de Marseille la
mèire de Marseille je l'ai eu la mère de
Marseille j'ai dû
l'appeler madame la sénatrice si vous
considérez que je dis n'importe quoi
suis sous serment il vous il ne tient
qu'à vous de d'engager la procédure qui
vous plaira sinon je continue s'il vous
plaît continuez monsieur min j'ai eu la
j'ai eu la mère de Marseille au
téléphone plusieurs fois cet été que
j'ai d'ailleurs moi-même appelé et qui
plusieurs fois m'a appelé pour que nous
échangions et je l'ai sensibilisé au
mois d'août en lui expliquant que les
indicateurs à Marseille devenaient
mauvais qu'il y avait des contaminations
chez un milieu jeune qu'il y avait des
soirées qu'on me déclarait sur des
rooftop en a d'ailleurs elle était tout
à fait consciente de ça et bien et bien
est totalement en phase avec ce que je
lui disais ce que nous échangions qu' y
avait des soirées qui étaient notamment
sur des rooftop qui pourent rassembler
plus de 1000 personnes sans masque sans
protection et que c'était dangereux pour
l'évolution de la situation le nous
avons eu un conseil de défense qui a
traité de la situation marseillaise qui
a proposé la mise en place concertée
entre le préfet et les élus d'un
couvre-feu qui affecterait les bar les
lieux de sortie à 11h du soir avec des
contrôles et cetera pour essayer de
freiner la diffusion et de montrer aussi
à la qu'attention attention la situation
commençait à devenir périlleuse je me
suis rendu à Marseille le 27 août et
j'ai passé je crois plus de 2 Hees en
préfecture de Marseille à discuter avec
les parlementaires les élus de la ville
de la métropole du département de la
région et plusieurs maires de communes
adjacentes de Marseille j'ai également
rencontré la mire de Marseille en
préfecture de Marseille pendant plus
d'une demi-heure et des échanges que
nous avons eu nous regardent ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'à l'époque je
leur ai dit que si nous ne prenions pas
rapidement des mesures de gestion pour
enrayer la circulation du virus il était
à craindre que nous soyons obligé de
prendre des mesures plus fortes plus
tard plus fortes plus tard j'ai discuté
également à la suite de cela avec les
élus marseillais qui considérait que
consulter n'était pas concerté sans
doute mais concerté ne veut pas dire
forcément tomber
d'accord ça ne veut pas dire forcément
tomber d'accord et à un moment donné le
principe de responsabilité il doit
primer et lorsqu'il faut protéger la vie
des gens lorsqu'il faut prendre des
mesures même difficiles pour éviter
qu'il y a des gens qui meurent il y a
une personne sur TR en réanimation qui a
moins de 65 ans et quand bien même il y
a deux personnes sur trois en
réanimation qui plus de 65 ans ce sont
des personnes qui n'ont pas demandé à
aller en réanimation ce sont des
personnes qui ont demandé à être
protéger et enrayer la circulation du
virus protéger les hôpitaux protéger les
réanimations protéger et soulager les
soignants vu la vague épidémique que
nous avons connu dans notre pays ça me
paraîttre agir en responsabilité et je
l'assume et je l'assumerai à chaque fois
que ce sera nécessaire on peut discuter
de la qualité d'une concertation de la
rapidité monsieur le sénateur jaumier je
vous ai lu dans la presse dire que le
ministre de la santé était sans AR en
train de courir après le virus si vous
voulez que nous ne courons pas après le
virus monsieur le sénateur il faut
accepter l'idée que nous soyons obligés
d'acter un certain nombre de décisions
rapidement cont tenu de la situation
sanitaire et si à chaque fois que nous
devons prendre des décisions nous devons
nous donner des jours de discussions
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à tomber
d'accord ou non sur des mesures de
gestion alors nous serons véritablement
en train de courir après le virus moi je
ne me laisse pas de boulet les boulets
c'est pas la concatation c'est les jours
de délai entre le moment où on observe
et le moment où on doit agir j'ai
entendu les critiques sur les mesures de
gestion prises soi-disant trop tard au
printemps le confinement qui était trop
tard et puis le confinement qui était
trop long puis le déconfinement qui
était trop tard puis le déconfinement
qui était trop tôt don acte quand vous
parlez de la confiance monsieur le
sénateur moi il y a une chose qui est
claire chez moi c'est la constance dans
le fait d'assumer les décisions de les
prendre et des mécanismes de
concertation qui font que ces décisions
sont prises sur la base de
recommandations scientifiques
en conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale sous la responsabilité du
Premier ministre et du président de la
République alors merci pour vos réponses
monsieur le ministre vous avez remarqué
tout de même que dans cette commission
d'enquête nous avons très peu parlé des
mois de mars avril mai parce qu'en fait
on a on a constaté que globalement les
pouvoirs
publics avaient pris dans le feu de l'p
mis probablement les mesures qui
s'imposaient en tout cas on n pas eu des
acteurs de terrain hormis la question de
cette distance avec les responsables
politiques que j'ai soulevé et je pense
que la qualité de la réponse ne
permettra pas de faire beaucoup
progresser les choses et j'en suis navré
mais si vous voulez que j'insiste
monsieur le ministre nous avons entendu
hier deux ministres une qui a dit le
problème c'est la culturation
scientifique des Français mais qui ne a
aucun un moment n'a envisagé le défaut
de culture de santé publique des
responsables politiques et de l'appareil
d'État qui est quand même aussi une
question qui est pas inintéressante
qu'on pourrait regarder quand même
tranquillement plutôt que dire à
culturation scientifique des Français et
une autre ministre dont le plaédoyer
pour nous faire part de son instruition
au mois de janvier était assez
convaincant et j'avais eu l'occasion de
le dire puisque vous aimez faire
référence aux propos pu
des uns et des autres était assez
convaincant mais ses propos pour nous
expliquer pourquoi le le le rela ne
s'est pas fait faire des décisions
rapides là n'était pas du tout
convaincant et d'ailleurs à ce sujet
elle nous a rappelé qu'on était en débat
sur la loi bioéthique pendant qu'elle se
préoccupait de l'épidémie elle avait
tout le loisir d'en parler avec le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales qui était assis à de mètres
d'elle donc avec les parlementaires avec
d'autres institutions et ça n'a jamais
été fait donc on vous appelle je vous
appelle juste non pas
à vous vous citez des tas de personnes
qui sont extérieur qui ont tenu des
propos qui qui conviennent pas qui sont
des oui don tact on y a eu droit ici
vous en faites pas c'est pas parce qu'on
écoute qu'on prend pour nous et qu'
qu'on fait opinion de ce qui nous est
dit et l'affrontement parfois ces
derniers jours vous l'avez vu assez
assez difficile la question n'est pas là
la question et de comprendre une
ministre a une intuition juste elle
comprend qu'il se passe quelque chose
pourquoi les décisions sont moins rapide
que dans d'autres pays la question n'est
pas de comparer point à point la
situation des pays vous parlez du Japon
vous dites ah ouais le Japon vous savez
c'est pas parce que ils ont bien testé
tracer isolé que l'épidémie s'est arrêta
oui mais Japon ils ont pas fermé les
restaurants non plus si on prend point à
point ces comparaisons ne valent pas
raison par contre ce que nous nous avons
fait la façon dont notre pays a réagi
puis notre société c'est là où je
voulais vous interroger parce que
évidemment que vous venez nous expliquer
que vous êtes un homme engagé engagé
dans la santé publique de longues dates
que vous prenez beaucoup de décision
vous avez au mois d'août compris que ça
il y avait quelque chose qui ne
fonctionnait pas mais alors pourquoi
cette
stratégie dont vous reconnaissez qu'elle
elle est dysfonctionnelle tester trac et
isolé pourquoi pourquoi est-elle restée
si longtemps dysfonctionnelle et
est-elle encore en partie au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous voulons comprendre
ces mécanismes là c'est ce qui nous
intéresse et non pas de mettre en cause
telle ou telle personne donc vous pouvez
garder un ton mesurer et posé ne pas
vous emporter et vous verrez on avancera
sur ces questions on monsieur le
ministre on ne doute pas de votre sens
des responsabilités Catherine Desroche
non mais j'avais levé la main mais en
fait Bernard jum a dit parce que ma
première question c'était quand même
celle-ci euh agès Bua nous a dit que
lorsqu'elle est partie et pourquoi il y
a eu un moment ce alors c'est vrai que
parmi tous les membres du gouvernement
qu'on qu'on a reçu du gouvernement passé
ou actuel je l'ai dit on n pas eu
beaucoup d'autocritique bon je l'entends
c'est toujours difficile lorsqu'on est
un homme politique de de reconnaître des
erreurs mais est-ce qu'il y a des points
quand même où en effet par rapport à ce
qu'on vient de dire il y a eu un moment
pour une raison X ou Y un temps de
latence si oui pourquoi et comment vous
souhaitez corriger
maintenant je comprends totalement votre
votre question je vais juste répondre
sur le la question de la culturation
scientifique et cetera monsieur le
sénateur oui soyez monsieur le ministre
bien concis maintenant dans vos
réponses les questions sont précises
elles sont précises mais j'en suis déjà
à une vingtaine de questions monsieur le
sénateur et je répondrai autant de
questions que vous le souhaiterez mais
c'est pour dire que c'est c'est des
questions qui sont complexes il y a il y
a une il y a eu un sondage qui est sorti
il y a quelques semaines en France
pensez-vous que tel traitement soit
efficace contre le
coronavirus on peut déjà se poser la
question de ce qui peut passer par la
tête d'un
sondeur pour se dire que les Français
ont nécessairement un avis sur un
traitement là où la communauté
scientifique n'a pas forcément
postulé il y avait une quarantaine de
pour de Français qui considéraent que le
traitement était efficace de mémoire un
autre entage assez important qui
considérait qu'il n'était pas efficace
il y avait je crois 20 ou 22 % de
Français qui ont répondu je ne sais
pas je je vais pas vous faire le coup de
60 millions d'épidémiologistes et et la
santé quand guilem avait dit avait écrit
la santé a remplacé le salut c'est
devenu un dogme myth c'est devenu aussi
un objet politique puissant le droit à
la
santé la nécessité de sécurité sociale
et de sécurité sanitaire ont émergé
comme des revendications politiques tout
à fait légitimes au au moment où le
patient se transformer se métamorphoser
en usager de la santé et c'est très bien
c'est très bien il y a eu la grande loi
du 4 mars 2002 de Bernard couchner sur
les droits des usagers des droits des
patients et on assiste à cette
transformation aussi irrigué par les
réseaux sociaux par les chaînes d'info
enue et cetera et on voit donc se
succéder sur l'ensemble des plateaux sur
les réseaux sur Twitter énormément de
gens qui vont dire une chose et son
contraire parfois quand on a de la
chance ce sont pas les mêmes personnes
qui disent une chose et leur contraire
d'une journée sur l'autre parfois quand
on a moins chance ce sont les mêmes
personnes qui sont capables de vous dire
une chose et sont contraire ils sont
rarement c'est arrivé réinterrogés sur
leurs propos du
passé mais tout cela je pense crée
beaucoup de
confusion ça veut pas dire que la
science soit l' panage des sachants et
des scientifiques et moi je suis médecin
comme vous monsieur jaumier et je
considère que une information doit être
claire loyale et appropriée et qu'elle
doit être comprise par les personnes
donc il faut faire en sorte qu'une
information puisse être comprise et pour
cela il faut être d'abord transparent
dans les données dont nous disposons
pour décider ce que j'ai fait encore
hier en montrant les courbes les
anticipations les simulations les
modalisations en mettant les réserves
d'usage parce que la science n'est pas
imparable et il faut expliquer et
prendre le temps d'expliquer de
réexpliquer le pourquoi des
décisions sur le sur savoir vous me
dites parfois vous avez trop tardé à
prendre des
décisions je ne suis pas là pour faire
le moratoire sur les décisions la façon
que je les prendre je vous invite juste
à faire le par entre ce que vous me
dites et ce que vous m'avez demandé
juste
auparavant vous décidez sans prendre le
temps de consulter les gens ou s'en
prendre le temps d'avoir une vraie
constatation parfois 2 jours c'est trop
parfois 2 jours c'est trop tard et
lorsque vous avez des chiffres
sanitaires qui montent et une pression
sanitaire qui monte de jours de jours ça
peut faire la différence de jours ça
peut faire la différence donc oui il
faut répondre en urgence j'étais
neurologue en unité de soins intensif
neurovasc ulaire à m'occuper des AVC à
faire des tromboises on dit là-bas que
le temps c'est du neurone quand j'ai
commencé on disait qu'on avait 1h30 pour
trombolyiser un malade sinon il risquait
de garder un handicap à vie physique
moteur sensitif ou perdre le langage à
vie donc prendre des décisions dans
l'urgence les assumer les expliquer ça
fait partie intégrante de ma formation
professionnelle de ma vocation de
médecin donc je l'assume pleinement je
dis pas que c'est simple je dis que oui
parfois il faut prendre des décisions
qui sont rapides et parfois on peut pas
les prendre trop vite non plus et pour
madame de roche je pourrais vous faire
ici la liste intéressante des des mot
moment où j'ai eu
à à tenter par tout moyen d'accélérer
enfin tout moyen LGO et raisonnable
d'accélérer des processus de
décision c'est pas simple et si vous me
demandez de savoir si je suis satisfait
de la façon dont tout a roulé et tout
c'est non non madame de roche Catrice
évidemment que non il y a eu plein de
fois où d'ailleurs la presse en est fait
écho sur les tests salivaires sur les
tests antigéniques que j'ai trouvé que
les recherches étaient trop longues ou
quand pour expérimenter un traitement
selon un protocole très célèbre
j'appelle des équipe médicale d'un grand
CHU pour leur dire ce serait bien que
vous reproduisiez cette expérimentation
pour qu'on puisse avoir des données on
vous accordera un comité de protection
des personne à CPP on vous autorise la
recherche on la finance ne vous
embarrassez pas faites-nous un protocole
simple basique pour qu'on puisse avancer
et qu'au bout de 2 semaines le protocole
est pas envoyé qu'on vous l'envoie un
jeudi soir et qu'on vous dit bah du coup
le comité des personnes se réunira la
semaine prochaine pour statuer non je
veux vous réunissiez samedi donc il faut
réunir les gens samedi par en
visionférence parce qu'ils peuvent pas
être réunis physiquement et puis ensuite
bah il y a des amendements sur le
protocole et et finalement vous vous
prenez un mois dans la vue évidemment
que si vous me posez la question de
savoir s'il m'est arrivé d'enrager
considérant que les choses étaient trop
longues oui je vais vous donner une
anecdote et j'arrêterai là merci
monsieur je vais vous donner une
anecdote et j'arrêterai là pour que
chacun puisse aussi lorsqu'il a fallu
qu'on a lorsqu'on a manqué des
couvillons en France parce que c'est un
producteur italien qui était le premier
producteur mondial et que les frontières
étaient fermées il y a une femme
formidable qui tient une entreprise
familiale dans l'heure qui s'appelle
madame Lemoine et que je remercie que
j'ai reçu au ministère qui faque des cô
ton tige et qui m'a dit les écouvillons
je peux les fabriquer je vais
transformer une usine de production elle
a fait son process industriel très
rapide mais comme c'est un dispositif
particulier les couvillons il faut le
stériliser il faut que ce soit l'embout
et cetera il faut forcément ça prend du
temps donc entre le moment où je
manquais des couvillons pour faire des
prélèvements en France où j'avais une
usine qui était capable de produire des
écouvillons mais où j'ai eu la
validation définitive que les nouveaux
écouvillons pouvaient servir sur les
malades il s'est écoulé des semaines et
on dit mais c'est pas possible je
préfère encore avoir des écouvion comme
ça mais non parce qu'il faut quand même
des processus de validation scientifique
on fait gaffe à tout on fait gaffe à
tout quand des masques arrivent de Chine
même si vous en manquez sur le
territoire vous les distribuez pas si la
douane n'a pas vérifié que les masques
sont conformes et efficaces et
efficients et ça prend des jours et ça
prend des jours entre le moment où vous
décidez de quelque chose et le moment où
la chose est opérationnelle et efficace
ça prend des jours nous avons un système
particulièrement normatif en France nous
avons fait sauter un paquet de normes
qui était illusoire et dérisoire pendant
la période j'ai signé des décrets des
arrêtés à tour de bras pour simplifier
les choses mais que voulez-vous il y a
des choses qui prennent du temps je
croyez-moi je le regrette au moins
autant que vous merci c'est ce qu'il
faudra
corriger arrêtons d'hypernormet dans le
processus législatif aussi bien ça c'est
bien ça c'est ce que je vous
dis est en contradiction avec la
métaphore guerrière Roger
carucci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre franchement depuis le début
de ces auditions je me dis il y a quand
même un
problème le problème n'est pas dans
cette commission d'enquête de dire il y
a des gouvernants qui vont être
responsable et un parlement qui veut
absolument mettre en cause leur
responsabilité mais peut-être qu'on peut
se dire dans un pays où il y a déjà eu
40000 morts que tout le monde doit
regarder un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
sincèrement les gouvernements précédents
le Parlement ont eu la responsabilité
aussi d'avoir réduit les moyens des des
hôpitaux de la santé et ils doivent
accepter cette responsabilité en tirer
les conséquences pour la suite après
personne ne met en cause monsieur le
ministre votre implication elle se voit
mais je c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est une opinion publique qui a peur
peur parce que l'épidémie reprend peur
parce que il y a pas de traitement pour
le moment peur parce qu'on ne sait pas
exactement quand est-ce qu'on aura le
vaccin il faut à la fois la protéger
la responsabiliser et la rassurer et
pour le moment on y est
pas vous faites des efforts et et je
vais vous poser une ou deux questions un
peu précises mais rapides pour pour être
plus clair mais on on sent bien bon le
débat médiatique est- ce qu'il est il
est normal tout le monde est devenu un
expert et comme aucun des experts n'est
d'accord ça rend la situation des
Français totalement anxiog jeune entre
ceux qui pensent que nous on sait rien
ceux qui pensent qu'ils vont mourir et
ceux qui pensent qu'on en est pas sorti
on sait plus où on en est et la parole
publique je reprends ce que disait
monsieur jaumier alors peut-être pas
exactement sur le même thème du lien sur
le thème de la crédibilité de la parole
publique moi je pense sincèrement je le
dis je l'ai dit à Darmanin je l'ai dit
aux uns aux autres et tout le monde
regarde ça mais il e fallu il faudrait
peut-être trouver un moyen pour qu'il y
ait une unité de la parole publique dans
cette
on ne peut pas avoir tous les ministres
aussi sympathique soit-il ou pas euh qui
viennent sur les écrans de télé raconter
leur vision de la crise le ministre de
la santé devrait être comme dans
d'autres pays pratiquement le seul
chargé de dire un certain nombre de
choses d'annoncer un certain nombre de
choses parce que c'est celui qui
logiquement doit gérer la crise
sanitaire la dispersion de la parole
publique et la dispersion de la parole
scientifique rendre le climat
extrêmement
anxiogène après il y a vous l'avez dit
la transparence et Monsieur le Ministre
une ou deux questions
simples vous avez dit avanthier de
mémoire que avec 950 personnes en
réanimation euh nous étions à 19 % de
nos capacités et actuel mais alors
euh j'ai un petit sujet parce que j'ai
eu une petite discussion un peu vive
avec les gens de la RS Île-de-France qui
disaient la même chose ou à peu près sur
le taux en Île-de-France 5500 l de
réanimation au début de la crise en
février-mars on nous a dit
progressivement une montée en puissance
pour être disait-on au mois de juillet
aux alentours de 10000 et on nous avait
dit qu'en Île-de-France on était passé à
peu près à 2200 2300 l de réanimation en
juillet comment par exemple vos 950
personnes l'animation peuvent faire 19 %
de 10000 j'ai un petit sujet
c'est-à-dire que à un moment soit vous
nous dites voilà où on en est pour de
bon et voilà ce qui va impliquer des
mesures comme la fermeture
d'établissement et cetera mais il faut
que qu'on comprenne j'ai entendu votre
passage à 14000 s'il faut mobiliser mais
où en est-on réellement aujourd'hui
est-on encore à 5500 est-on à 10000
a-t-on des capacités supplémentaires
complètes complètes pas avec des
respirateurs d' point si oui euh on est
dans une meilleure situation et la
dramatisation a peut-être du sens pour
des mesures économiques elle n'en a pas
pour rassurer les gens deuxième point
sur sur les traitements on entend tout
et n'importe quoi certains disent mais
il y a rien bon très bien et puis de
temps en temps on a un
responsable sanitaire qui dit mais si si
ça c'est nettement améliorer sur le
traitement des patients parce que on a
une meilleure connaissance on a quand
même un certain nombre de médicaments où
est-ce qu'on en est vraiment vraiment
est-ce que les gens peuvent se
dire le le taux pratiquement de
mortalité qu'on a eu au printemps ne
peut plus être le cas parce que on les
traite mieux et parce qu'on sait où on
en est enfin dernière élément et ce sera
ma dernière question vous avez parlé de
de des réserves enfin des commandes de
vaccin fait par la France ou par la
Commission européenne mais je vois que
par
exemple le groupe Johnson and Joh dit
qu'il est nettement plus avancé et que
il avance à un point tel que visiblement
il serait peut-être peut-être j'en sais
rien en avant sur les autres groupes sur
la mise au point du vaccin est-ce que ça
veut dire que en réalité la France est
placée de manière telle ou l'Union
européenne sont placé de manière telle
que quel que soit le groupe qui a le
vaccin le plus sûr le plus rapidement
nous sommes dans la phase de de capacité
cité de vacciner les Français ou bien
est-ce que nous attendons les vaccins
des groupes à qui nous avons commandé
même s'ils sont en
retard merci Olivier h
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre on a vécu hier l'audition de
Madame Buzin et incontestablement
c'était un moment assez fort et on a
bien compris qu'il y avait une intuition
euh des plus hautes autorités et un
retard dans dans l'exécution
des des mesures qui étaient à prendre et
elle a dit ceci il y a eu une sorte de
dénis y compris dans les administrations
dans les hôpitaux chez les médecins
notre société n'a pas cru qu'on pouvait
mourir en France est-ce que lorsque vous
avez pris et puis après on s'interroge
aussi sur le périmètre de ce dénis hein
elle a pas abordé cette question
naturellement enfin nous on s'interroge
sur le périmètre du dénis jusqu'à quel
niveau il y a une forme de dénis et
est-ce que vous lorsque vous avez pris
vos fonctions vous vous avez ressenti le
même dénis à la mi-février c'est la
première question la deuxième est est
plus technique elle concerne les tests
vous avez abordé la question de la
régulation moi je vous interrogerai sur
la notion de souveraineté quel est notre
niveau de dépendance vis-à-vis de l'Asie
sur sur ces tests et et aussi sur la
question des prix hein puisque lorsqu'on
compare il semble qu'il y a une
différence de prix à l'intérieur de de
l'Europe entre le prix du test ici en
France et ce qui se passe en Espagne on
est presque à à à 50 % de différence
est-ce que vous avez une explication sur
cette différence je vous remercie merci
Jean
sol monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je salue tout d'abord l'hommage
que vous venez de rendre à la communauté
hospitalière aux équipes médicales et
paramédicales qui n'ont pas toujours été
jusque-l reconnu à leur juste valeur en
tout cas c'est mon point de vue et
accompagné dans leurs attente légitime
en terme notamment de moyens humains et
logistiques monsieur le ministre vous
êtes sous cerment le 26 février le match
Olympique Lyonnais Juventus de tour de
Turin pardon s s'est déroulé à Lyon 3000
supporters desbqu d'Italie au moment où
l'Italie devient le pays d'Europe le
plus contaminé au
coronavirus pourquoi avez-vous donc
autoriser cette rencontre
ou sinon qui vous a poussé à autoriser
cette rencontre je vous remercie
merci Angèle
Préville merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre alors moi je vais
revenir sur la stratégie de lutte contre
l'épidémie et comme vous l'avez dit une
information doit être comprise je vais
revenir sur le nombre de décès en
épad sur concernant donc les personnes
âgées et qui visiblement n'a pas été la
priorité absolue de la France dès lors
qu'on a isolé les épades cet isolement
pour être efficace aurait dû inclure
un des consignes notamment et cela va du
cuisinier qui opère dans la cuisine des
épades jusqu'au livreur or ces
personnes-là euh n'ont pas reçu des
consignes d'être protégé et donc il
s'est produit ce qui devait se produire
c'est-à-dire que le virus est entré dans
les épades et euh pour mon département
et pour mon territoire qui a été très
peu touché c'est le département du lotte
dans commune la commune limitrophe et
deux autres établissements très proches
de ma commune la moitié des résidents
étai covid plus
donc on peut se réinterroger sur bah les
consignes c'est vrai l'isolement était
sans doute une bonne chose mais ça
devait s'assortir bien évidemment d'une
consigne claire alors ma question c'est
quelles étaient les consignes comment
elles sont parvenues au au directeurs
des établiss
et quand la publiquement vous avez
annoncé que les épades allaient être
isolé est-ce qu'il ne fallait pas dire
immédiatement pour que ce soit clair
pour tout le monde que toute personne
qui
aurait à faire avec les épades devrait
être protégé voilà c'est ma question
merci merci Victor jasem et on arrêtera
là pour la première
sallecip merci victoire oui merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre euh en Guadeloupe la
situation est critique nous sommes dans
le rouge après la Guyane et Mayotte qui
s'en sont sortis plus ou moins
aujourd'hui la situation est dramatique
alors il y a plusieurs niveau de
questions j'en Auris trois la première
c'est le cri d'alarme du directeur
général monsieur Gérard côtellon le
directeur général du CHU qui ce CHU qui
avait déjà des difficultés depuis son
incendie mais et ce CHU reste encore
l'hôpital euh principal et euh c'est
pour le GHT l'hôpital ressources
pourtant il y a des comités euh des
comités de de suivi qui se tiennent avec
Monsieur le Préfet où il y a les élus et
toutes les strates sont invités et le
directeur général d'après euh les
informations que nous avons eu n'était
pas forcément invité d'autre part nous
sommes maintenant dans une situation
très grave
et les moyens manquent alors qu'il y
avait déjà des difficultés à
l'infrastructurelle des différentes
carences au niveau des équipements vous
le saviez parce que plusieurs fois
madame votre prédécesseur s'est déplacé
ces derniers temps enfin pendant qu'elle
é en fonction et la situation
aujourd'hui n'a pas tellement évolué ici
même il y a 2 jours la ministre des
armées a fait un certain nombre
d'annonces et de propositions qu'elle
ferait pour le pour le conseil de de des
armées de défense je souhaerais savoir
Monsieur le Ministre si les mesures que
vous avez annoncé vous et Monsieur le
Premier Ministre sont en cohérence avec
les réels besoins de ce
territoire il y a eu certes des annonces
concernant l'envoi de personnel des
armées le personnel médicaux peut-être
aussi paramédicaux je n'ai pas le détail
mais est-ce que la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants vous semble une réponse
pertinente cont tenu de la situation à
la fois des professionnels qui sont
épuisés mais aussi des personnes contact
et des personnes malades pour la plupart
aujourd'hui d'après les informations que
j'ai est-ce que la plateforme de
biologie pour les Antilles qui est un
projet qui n'est toujours pas abouti et
qui devait déjà aboutir et les limites
des moyens que la RS met à disposition
du CHU en particulier et des hôpitaux de
façon
générale ne n'explique pas aussi les
difficultés n'amplifie pas les
difficultés qui sont déjà quand même
assez importants alors monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais vraiment savoir
quelles sont les mesures que vous
comptez prendre à partir de maintenant
pour que à la fois les mesures tant
techniques médico-technique et médical
soit prise en compte pour que le
directeur du CHU soit également impliqué
dans toutes les décisions qui concerne
le territoire parce qu'en tant que chef
de fil pour les ght je je crois qu'il
devrait être impliqué dans les comités
de suivi parce que les maires ou leur
représentants le Conseil départemental
le conseil régional et tous les
parlementaires il participent en
fonction de leur disponibilité
respective évidemment et c'est vraiment
dommage que contrairement à ce qui vient
être dit concernant les élusci les élus
soient en première ligne et le directeur
du CH qui a la responsabilité et bien il
n'est pas forcément suffisamment écouté
et entendu et c'est son communiqué qu'il
a rendu public et vous avez sans doute
eu les remontées de ce communiqué qui
était quand même assez assez dur parce
que quand on est directeur général de l'
hôpital et qu'on écrit tout cela c'est
qu'on a quand même gr la patate si je
peux me permettre de le dire je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
cétait
vous bien monsieur le sénateur carucci
merci pour vos pour vos questions
d'abord dire qu'il y a pas eu 40000
morts mais 31000
morts pr 40000 31000 vous savez que la
France dispose de données on appelle les
données Inc sur la surmortalité observée
une année par rapport aux années
précédentes nous avions déclaré 30000
morts à l'époque ça faisait 15 jours que
les gazettes se faisaient lesco de morts
cachées à domicile on avait même vu des
études faites par je ne sais quelle
structure disant qu'il y avait 10000
mors cachées à l'hôpital suite à des
cour quand vous comparez la mortalité
sur le l'année sur la période de la
première vague versus la même période
les années précédentes on aurait dû
attendre à ce qu'il ait 20 ou 25000
morts et nous en avons des déclaré 30
donc ça veut dire que non seulement il y
a pas eu de mort cachée mais
probablement qu'un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont décédées porteurs du
covid ne sont pas nécessairement décédés
du covid bien premier point et c'est
important parce que je pense que si on
avait dû comme certains pays voisins
rajouter 15000 morts du jour au
lendemain je pense à nos amis anglais
notamment je pense que ça aurait été
plus compliqué devant vous aujourd'hui
de justifier 950 patients en RA vous
avez parfaitement raison monsieur le
sénateur ça ne correspond pas à 19 % du
nombre de lit maximum armé qu'on peut
avoir dans les hôpitaux mais ça
correspond effectivement bien à 19 % des
lit actuellement armé ce que j'ai dit en
préambule et qui est fondamental c'est
qu'à chaque fois que vous armez un lit
de réanimation vous désarmez un bloc
opératoire vous annulez des chirurgies
cancérologiques vous annulez de la
greffe vous annulez de la chirurgie
orthopédique vous annulez des St
coronariens vous annulez toute cette
activité réglée indispensable pour la
santé de celles et ceux de concitoyens
qui n'ont pas le covid
et donc ce n'est pas parce que je dis
que nous serions capable si la situation
l'exigeait et je touche le bois du Sénat
pour que ça n'arrive évidemment pas nous
serions capable d'augmenter fortement le
nombre de lits que nous avons envie
d'augmenter le nombre de lit donc plus
nous plus nous mettons la pression sur
le virus pour qu'il se réduise moins
nous prenons de risque de se nous voir
obliger de recommencer à appeler des
gens qui sont en difficulté sanitaire
pour leur dire qu'on peut pas s'occuper
d'eux parce qu'il faut prioriser les lit
vous comprenez donc on tient compte du
taux d'occupation des R normal si la
situation devit l'exiger on ferait ce
qu'on a fait la dernière fois on
augmenterait le nombre de Ré le
traitement c'est la dexaméthasone qui
est aujourd'hui le traitement qui qui
fonctionne en tout cas qui apporte un
une plusvalue c'est en pratique courant
dans tous les hôpitaux français toutes
les équipes l'utilisent c'est des
recommandations internationale c'est un
usage courant pas pas attention pas chez
n'importe quel cas covid si je si j'ai
demain le covid de ce que j'espère pas
et que j'ai 38 de fièvre une petite tou
je vais pas prendre ce médicament par
contre si je suis hospitalisé et que les
équipes considèrent que mon état
justifie ce dérivé de la cortisone bien
connu pas cher et et dont on a des
stocks euh ils peuvent le ils peuvent me
le donner et ça réduit les cas graves ça
réduit la mortalité et ça réduit la
durée de séjour en réa ce qui est aussi
important parce que les durée de séjour
en réa quand on les réduit bah ça
augmente aussi factuellement les
capacités de réanimation et l'autre
traitement dont on nous dit les
réanimateurs nous disent que maintenant
ils ont la la pratique courante c'est
l'oxygène a très très très haut début
c'est-à-dire 50 L minutes par des par
euh directement dans le nez ce qui évite
d'avoir à intuber les gens et de les
mettre en Comat
parce que l'intubation sur des poumons
fragilisés par le virus crée des lésions
respiratoires et des voies aériennes qui
peut entraîner des séquelles et aggraver
encore les choses donc on réduit en fait
le nombre de malade inbé et on réduit
les durées de de réa par contre du coup
le recours au lit d'hospitalisation non
réa est plus important qu'au cours de la
première vague parce que les gens iront
moins réa mais ils iront plus à
l'hôpital donc on fait très attention
aussi à ce que il n'y ait pas une
pression trop forte sur le capacitaire
en Lig d'hospitalisation conventionnelle
quant au vaccin je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est la com Commission
européenne maintenant avec des experts
de tous les pays en indépendance
évidemment vis-à-vis des l'origine des
laboratoires dont il s'occupent qui qui
travaille avec chaque labo qui est en
avance de phase pour pouvoir faire ce
qu'on appelle des engagements de
précommande converti en précommande
converti en commande lorsque la
situation le nécessite j'ai cité le
chiffre de 300 millions de doses par
exemple pour le vaccin AstraZeneca qui
étit passé en précommande par la
Commission européenne fait le calcul ça
fait beaucoup de dose et ça permet de
couvrir donc on c'est vraiment il y a un
travail qui qui est est qui conduit
extrêmement attentif et je pense que
cette ce travail doit se jouer à
l'échelle européenne je pense que ça
fait sens vous en conviendrez et en plus
ça nous rend plus puissant au moment de
contractualiser à la fois sur les
négociations de prix et à la fois sur la
capacité à garantir l'accès précoce au
marché européens pour monsieur le
sénateur ça répond pas à la question si
je voulais répondre à votre question
mais vous me citez un laboratoire en
particulier monsieur le sénateur c'est
c'est c'est non non mais le laboratoire
Johnson Johnson fait partie des 18 ou 20
laboratoires qui ont un vaccin en projet
d'étude il est très certainement en lien
avec la Commission européenne au même
titre que n'importe quel autre labo euh
finalement l'un des seuls laboratoires
qui ne produit pas de vaccin c'est un
laboratoire dont on dit que si nous
n'utilisons pas un certain traitement
c'est pour favoriser ce laboratoire bon
bref passons le pour le sénateur Eno euh
il y a pas eu de de dénis monsieur le
sénateur en tout cas pas plus en ce qui
me concerne qu'en ce qui concerne ma
prédécesseur je prends mes fonctions un
lundi matin je fais la passation de
pouvoir à 10h j'enchaîne avec une
réunion avec le Premier ministre qui
m'accueille et nous parlons beaucoup de
l'épidémie ce n'est pas que ce n'est pas
la question de Monsieur ho
hein
j'aiz pas est-ce qu'il y a un dénis dans
le pays vous voilà c'est ça c'est ce que
c'est ce que disait c'est pas moi qui le
dit d'ailleurs c'est Madame Buin
d'accord est-ce qu'il y a eu un dénis
dans le
pays écoutez je je une menace devient
réelle lorsquelle est aux pores ou
lorsqu'elle frappe est-ce qu'il y a eu
un dénis dans notre pays moi je pourrais
vous dire qu'il y a presque une forme de
dénis pas de tout le Pay pays mais d'une
partie du pays il y a encore 3 semaines
dans notre pays bah je dire j'ai passé
mon temps encore une fois je le redis
mais c'est important j'ai passé une mois
d'août et le début du mois de septembre
à expliqué qu'il y avait pas de raison
de penser que le virus a décidé tout
d'un coup de faire ce que les virus ne
font jamais c'est-à-dire perdre en
dangerosité vis-à-vis de son hôte et que
c'est pas parce que les jeunes se
contaminaient c'est parce que les jeunes
étaient beaucoup étaient nombreux à se
contaminer qu'il y avait moins
d'hospitalisation mais que les jeunes
allaient contaminer les moins jeunes et
qu'il y aurait autant d'hospitalisations
monsieur le sénateur je vous laisse juge
de regarder les les
presses on reste on reste dans une forme
de on n pas parle devant mais par par de
par il il y a peut-être une forme de
pensée magique qui fait qu'on on en a
dire on est à la fois dans un effort de
résilience collective qui est intense
les gens n'ont pas pu enterrer leur mort
en famille les gens ont perdu leur
emploi les enfants ne sont pas allés à
l'école des gens ont perdu des proches
des soignants sont épuisés et notre
système a été mis à rue d'épreuve comme
jamais dans notre histoire en tout cas
pas de monond vivant donc il y a ce
travail de résilience collective on a on
a on a plus envie de l'épidémie moi pas
plus que vous et pas plus que n'importe
quel français on a envie que ça s'arrête
et donc quand on voit que les
indicateurs sont meilleurs qu'on est en
train de passer à autre chose que c'est
la période estivale et plusieurs fois je
l'ai dit d'ailleurs cet été je comprends
le désir des jeunes de retrouver une vie
je dire les jeunes pardon je m'associe
aux jeunes j'ai 40 ans mais je me mets
dans cette génération Y fauellement j'y
suis qui a connu la pandémie qui a connu
les attentats terroristes qui connaît le
réchauffement climatique le chômage de
masse et la crise économique c'est lourd
donc moi j'ai jamais voulu être dans une
position paternaliste ou moralisatrice
ou hyper hygiéniste juste sensibiliser
en disant ne croyez pas que c'est sans
danger ne croyez pas que c'est sans
danger ce que je disais hier soir on
ferait un petit effort chacun d'entre
nous supplémentaire un petit effort au
lieu de recevoir 15 copains à la maison
et ben on va recevoir 5 ou si et si on a
vu 5 ou si copains dans un bar cette
semaine et ben on va pas en revoir 5 ou
si différents le lendemain c'est comme
ça qui circule le virus on fait
attention et qu'un fois qu'on a mis le
masque au Sénat dans l'hémicycle et
qu'on le met dans la voiture ou dans le
métro pour retourner chez soi si chez
soi on accueille 10 amis pour faire un
pour faire un déjeuner certes pendant
qu'on pendant qu'on mange on l'enlève
mais quand on est comme ça on se prend
pas dans les bras on se sert pas la main
et cetera et ça les Français sont très
majoritaires à l'avoir compris mais on a
vu des scènes y compris d'ailleurs dans
des villes qui sont pourtant en
situation d'alerte des fusions de joie
pour des matchs de foot ou autre où les
gens ne sont sont sans distance JEI à
chaque fois que je vois ça je je je je
souffre parce que je je vois le
j'imagine la diffusion et transmission
du virus bref pardon je digresse pardon
je dig donc vous partagez cette notion
un peu de non je dirais pas que c'est un
déni parce que le dé le déis c'est quand
on veut pas c'est c'est presque
psychologique c'est pas un déni voilà
bien la question de la souveraineté on
n'est pas on n'est pas en dépendance
totale vis-à-vis de l'Asie pour les
tests parce qu'on a des grands
fabricants de produits notamment à nos
portes et même en France par contre pour
les médicaments oui monsieur sénateur on
est totalement dépendant de l'étranger
on est dépendant pour les chaînes de
fabrication on est on est dépendant pour
les pour les matières premières à plus
de 90 % de quelques pays c'est dangereux
c'est irresponsable il est irresponsable
que la France se soit totalement
départie et l'Europe se soit départie de
capacité de production de choses qui
sauvent des vies je le dis et c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui ni d'hier c'est pas votre
faute ni la mienne ça fait des années
voir des décennies c'est irresponsable
nous devons retrouver de la souveraineté
européenne pour tout ce qui peut être
indispensable pour nous vous avez voté
et je vous en remercie l'année dernière
j'en c'est pas le porteur mais le
rapporteur à l'Assemblée nationale une
disposition qui prévoit qu'on oblige les
labos à stocker des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur sur le
territoire européen on va aller plus
loin il faut réindustrialiser mais ce
sera pas simple parce que quand vous
aurez des sites C vaau à implanter un
peu partout en Europe ce sera plus
compliqué il faut le faire sur le le le
prix de ces tests plusieurs choses
d'abord il faut que vous sachiez que la
France te prend en charge à 100 % sans
condition et qu'on est les seuls à le
faire personne n'avance de frais et il y
a des pays dont la part de remboursement
par les systèmes de santé est moins
importante que ce qu'on rembourse mais
où il y a un reste à charge demander aux
gens attention faut pas faut comparer
des choses qui sont comparables par
ailleurs les laboratoires sont amenés à
équiper à s'équiper en plateforme de de
de od débit PCR en masse on leur demande
de faire encore plus d'effort d'acheter
des matériels et cetera il est important
de leur donner l'assurance qu'ils vont
pas le faire à perte quand on leur
demande d'embaucher en CDD ou en CDI des
salariés pour faire des prélèvements ou
faire tourner les bécanes c'est
important qu'il ait de la lisibilité
sur la question qui portait sur les
moyens sur les moyens hospitaliers ils
ont été ils ont été au-delà de de la
crise le Ségure de la Santé prévoit de
remercier non seulement de reconnaître
les soignants et les soignantes avec 8
milliards d'euros de revalorisation j'ai
annoncé hier en comité de suivi de
segéure que la première tranche de 90 €
net par mois est versée dès la fin du
mois de septembre pour les hôpitaux et
les épades qui le peuvent ou en octobre
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas donc on a
anticipé les mesures séures création de
4000 lit supplémentaires là où on en
fermait des milliers années après années
dans notre pays et le recrutement de
15000 soignants supplémentaires pour
faire en sorte que les équipes ne soient
pas déstabilisées sur la question du
match Lyon tururin je reprends les dates
du match Lyon tururin d'abord je
pourrais vous dire que c'est pas
la alors c'est le 26 février oui tout à
fait mais c'est pas la compétence du
ministre mais c'est les compétences d'un
préfet de département de faire une
annulation mais une fois qu'on s'est dit
ça on s'est rien dit d'un point de vue
épidémiologique le 26 février le Piémont
et donc la ville de Turin ne faisait pas
partie des zones d'exposition à risque
telles que définies par Canté publique
France il y avait en Italie la Lombardie
et la Vénétie et plus tard étendu au
Piémont et à l'Émilie Romagne en outre
il faut noter en France l'absence au
mois de février de circulation active du
virus aucun cluster n'était alors
signalé en région over gronalpe en
dehors du cluster des Contamines qui
était considéré comme maîtrisé au-delà
l'Italie n'avait pas besoin qu'on
instaure des frontières avec elle elle
avait instauré ses propres frontières
puisqu'elle avait interdit les
circulations en dehors des territoires
concernés par la diffusion du virus je
pourrais ajouter à cela que lorsque la
question du match s'est posée il y avait
déjà un grand nombre de supporters
italiens qui étaient dans les rues des
villes française et que donc il aurait
été pas forcément plus safe d'avoir ses
supporters rassemblés dans des bars que
les avoir dans une enceinte extérieure
dans un stade de foot et par ailleurs il
n'y a pas eu de cluster issu de cette
rencontre il n'y a pas eu de diffusion
du virus du fait de ce match de football
sur la question des éepades qui est une
question éminemment importante et je ne
peux pas évidemment laisser insinuer
qu'on aurait fait moins attention parce
qu'on a fait une attention de tous les
instants aux éepad de tous les instants
madame la
sénatrice le 5 mars des consignes
d'hygiène des mesures d'orientation
interne des réflexes à avoir pour la
prise en charge des résidents ayant des
signes é voocateurs de covid sont portés
et les premières restrictions sur les
visites sont portées difficile déjà
comme décision le 6 mars je déclenche le
Plan bleu dans les épades qui organise
le plan de crise dans les épades avec
par exemple exemple les gestes barrières
le 11 mars je suis amené à interdire les
visites des Pres dans les épades
interdire les visites de pres dans les
épades le 22 mars la règle de
distribution des masques est faite et
affinée en lien avec toutes les
instances scientifiques de et les
représentants du monde de la gériatrie
le 23 mars une stratégie sanitaire de
soutien aux épad sur la base d'un rétex
d'un retour d'expérience faite dans les
régions les plus touchées est établi le
28 mars je demande la limitation des
déplacements au sein des établissements
pouvant aller jusqu'au en chambre sur
appréciation de l'équipe après avoir
saisi pour cela le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique et le Conseil
Scientifique le 30 mars j'annonce
l'accès prioritaire au test de dépistage
pour les résidents des pad et les
personnels au fur et à mesure de
l'augmentation des capacités des tests
conformément aux recommandations du
Conseil Scientifique et le 7 avril je
fais un élargissement massif de cette
doctrine de dépistage dans les
épades madame la sénatrice je l'ai déjà
dit humainement ça a été les décisions
les plus dures à prendre de toute la
crise et la décision de confinement en
chambre notamment je l'ai prise après
avoir consulté des directeurs d'pad et
des directeurs de groupe d'pad qui
disposaient d'établissement dans les
pays à l'étranger qui avaient connu la
vague avant nous et qui m'ont fait part
de leur retour d'expérience qui était
que une fois que le virus rentre se
moyen de l'arrêter c'est d'isoler tout
le monde et donc on avait hier 180
clusters actifs dans les épases encore
nous avons fait le
choix de protéger sans isoler et c'est
fondamental et donc nous apprenons de
cela parce que nous ne vons pas que le
syndrome de glissement des personnes
âgées en épad s'accélère encore sur la
question de la Guadeloupe qui est
éminemment éminemment importante alors
je suis très étonné si le directeur
général du CSU n'est pas associé à la
gestion de crise ce serait ça j'ai
regardé je vous promets j'ai pas vu la
la lettre du directeur j'étais hier très
chargé mais je vais regarder cela et il
est important que le directeur du CU
soit évidemment en première ligne dans
l'association oui la situation sanitaire
en Guadeloupe madame la sénatrice est un
inquiétante elle est inquiétante c'est
l'une des situations les plus dégradées
la plus dégradée que que nous ayons
c'est aussi inquiétant parce que il y a
des un sujet avec Saint-Martin avec une
porosité des frontières qui a été qui a
été plus enfin voilà c'était plus simple
enfin on a c'est moins compliqué à gérer
avec les frontières à une époque que ça
peut l' être aujourd'hui et puis des
problèmes sanitaires sur Saint-Martin la
mobilisation de la réserve sanitaire est
totale depuis plusieurs semaines il y a
eu plusieurs dizaines de médecins
d'infirmiers d'êt soignants
d'épidémiologistes d'experts qui ont été
envoyés le service de santé des armées
est pleinement mobilisé un EMR
c'est-à-dire l'hôpital militaire qui
avait été utilisé à mulouse qui avait
été utilisé à Mayotte est en route pour
la Guyane à laquelle je vous parle il
arrivera le 25 monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi il y a 2 jours madame
parli nous a dit que cette demande dit
quo j'ai formulé la demande et elle nous
a dit qu'il que les que qu'on aurait eu
sur la Guadeloupe probablement les
moyens humain mais qu' n était pas
nécessaire qu'il y ait les moyens oui
vous avez la place vous allez vous
mettre d'accord l'essentiel c'est que
faire vous avez vous allez avoir les moy
venir monsieur le ministre vous allez
avoir les moy pardon pardon écoutez
pardon vous avez vous allez avoir les
moyens de l'EMR donc les moyens de cet
hôpital militaire qui sont sur place le
25 c'est-à-dire nous sommes le donc
c'est demain et qui seront opérationnels
le 28 donc croyez-moi nous faisons
extrêmement attention et et il y a eu
des départs des épidémies estivales en
Guyane à Mayot donc d'autres territoires
ultramarins que nous avons réussi à
enrayer à endiguer avec un impact
sanitaire en terme de mortalité qui
était plus bien plus faible que celui
que nous avions constaté en première
vague donc nous faisons vraiment le le
le maximum pour cela
euh la plateforme au débit pour les an
parce que il y a un dossier qui y a une
demande et pour le moment ça stagne
alors qu'est-ce qui
freine concernant la concernant la
plateforme od dans le oui concernant
tout le monde la la situation
glaudeloupe est suffisamment
préoccupante pour qu'on fasse un petit
focus dessus oui mais monsieur le
Président alors concern nous venons
d'avoir une autre réponse mais j'avais
j'avais justement concernant les moyens
qui étaient mobilisés à mulouse je l'ai
explicitement demandé à madame la
ministre qui était ici il y a 2 jours et
vous avez tous entendu sa réponse là
c'est plutôt rassurant les annonces de
monsieur le ministre je vous remerci
d'avance concernant la plateforme au
débit qui a été qui étaé demandé à la
fois par le directeur général de du CHU
monsieur côellon il y a un projet qui
n'avance pas qui est bloqué donc ça ça
allonge en fait les délais de rendu des
analyses contenu des moyens existants ne
permettent pas de prendre en charge
rapidement les personnes qui seraient
éventuellement des personnes contact
mais aussi des personnes qui seraient
euh euh euh des personnes entre Guillet
porteur sans disons donc ça pose un
problème très très rapidementadame la
sénatrice ce que je vous propose c'est
que autant tant sur la composition de
l'EMR qui va arriver en Guadeloupe que
les moyens qui vont être engagés que sur
la situation particulière de la
plateforme au débit PCR pour l'hôpital
de Guadeloupe je vous propose de revenir
vers vous avec les données chiffréses et
factuelles précises je vais appeler
également ma collègue des armées pour
voir si les choses moi je nai pas la
main sur le SSA je ne vrais pas vous
induire en erreur évidemment je vous
donne les informations dont je disposais
à date d'hier soir je vous on vous
donnera cet après-midi l'ensemble des
informations précises ça vous convient
et vouslez communiquer monsieur le
ministre à la Commission pour que ça
figure effectivement dans la réponse
bien sûr il y a aucun problème Céline
boulet
eséronier merci monsieur le Président je
rejoins complètement les positions de
mon collègue Roger carucci quand il
parle de l'importance de la parole
publique et d'uniformité de celle-ci
surtout quand elle a été mise à mal au
début de la pandéie de la pandémie par
contre là où je ne le rejoint pas c'est
quand il dit que l'ensemble de la
population est très inquiète parce qu'il
me semble que l'une des difficultés que
vous avez gérer c'est qu'il y a une
partie de la population qui est inquiète
et une partie qui n'est peut-être pas
assez il y a une contradiction là-dessus
d'où l'importance de l'uniformité de la
parole publique et que à chaque fois
qu'une information est donnée elle ne
soit pas trop contestée et j'en reviens
au sujet de la culturation des français
à partir du moment où chaque Français
est concerné par cette maladie à partir
du moment où on en appelle à la
responsabilité de chaque Français il est
normal que chaque Français aille
chercher le niveau de connaissance qui
qui va l'aider à surmonter cette période
qui est som toute assez compliquée et je
crois que la parole publique doit
composer avec ce qu'il se dit dans les
médias et ce qu'il se dit sur les
réseaux sociaux et la difficulté est que
il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes qui sont
dites d'où l'importance qui est lié
cette uniformité ça c'était une
réflexion personnelle et puis on a parlé
de dénis et on pourrait digresser
là-dessus de nombreuses minutes mais moi
j'ai trois questions assez
précises la première concerne les test
et afin de réduire les tensions sur les
laboratoires n'est-il pas temps de
réinstaurer la prescription obligatoire
pour les tests PCR en encourageant
fortement la téléconsultation et avoir
une communication claire
là-dessus évidemment c'est test et c'est
c'est qui qui sont pris en charge à 100
% par l'assurance maladie et la
téléconsultation il en a été question
dans le segure sur la santé mais je
pense qu'il va falloir avoir une vraie
réflexion là-dessus à l'avenir parce que
c'est vraiment une une valeur d'avenir
et on aura l'occasion d' parler ma
deuxième question concerne le niveau de
connaissance sur les séqueles des
patients qui ont déjà été atteints de du
covid surtout euh à l'amorce de l'hiver
parce que là aussi les les informations
les plus fantaisistes parfois circulent
là-dessus et puis aussi notamment sur
est-ce qu'il est possible de le
rattraper et cetera je voudrais savoir
le niveau de connaissance parce qu'on
parle des malades qui pourrai attraper
le covid mais il y a aussi de nombreux
malades qui l'ont eu et savoir comment
ça va évoluer est-ce qu'ils peuvent le
le le réavoir excusez-moi je voilà
j'essaie de terminer savoir si les
malades qui ont le peuvent le réavoir et
j'ai une petite question oui pardon
pardon connexe par rapport à la question
des tests j'entends dire que les tests
sont plus chers en France que dans de
nombreux pays européens y y a-t-il une
raison à cela et est-ce que c'est vrai
je crois que ça avait été é vovoquer
mais je voulais avoir la précision
là-dessus et enfin monsieur le ministre
je voudrais savoir votre position par
rapport au
télétravail est-ce que vous dites qu'il
faut l'encourager dans les
entreprises euh et peut-être nous les
nous les parlementaires devrons
légiférer là-dessus lors du PLFSS je ne
sais pas j'aimerais avoir votre position
là-dessus je vous
remercie merci Laurence
Cohen merci Monsieur le le Président
Monsieur le le ministre pour qu'il n'y
ait pas d'ambigué parce que c'est
toujours un exercice difficile
personnellement je fais partie des élus
qui ne doutent absolument pas de la
mobilisation des services du ministère
et effectivement on ne peut que les
saluer pas plus d'ailleurs de votre
propre mobilisation monsieur le ministre
ni de celle de Madame Buin donc ça c'est
pour ce qui ne va pas
empêcher voilà ça ça voilà non mais
c'est pour relever enlever toute ambigué
parce que je sens bien que quand on émet
un certain nombre de critiques ça
devient très conflictuel donc ça ne met
pas en cause individuellement les les
personnes mais on est ici et en cela je
partage ce qu'a dit Roger kucci là on
mais on est quand même ici par rapport à
des choix politiques un certain nombre
d'entre eux vous incombent et d'autres
étaient entérieur à votre prise de
fonction et bien sûr vous ne on ne vous
demande pas de tout endosser mais est-ce
que à la lumière de ce que nous vivons
vous allez modifier un certain nombre de
choses parce que il y a des choses à
modifier et la première de mes questions
c'est que vous savez vraiment
pertinemment que notre système de santé
était est en tension avant cette
pandémie et singulièrement l'hôpital que
ça continue à être en en tension et vous
vous vous le savez d'autant plus que il
y a eu très récemment une la démission
assez fracassante du chef de service des
urgences de kremelinbisset valdeemarne
le département dont je suis l'élu le
docteur Maurice raphaelll qui est un
homme extraordinaire qui était en
fonction depuis 10 ans euh qui ne
comptait pas ses heures je vous rappelle
que c'est un des services d'urgence les
plus importants de l'île-de-fance près
de 60000 entrées par an et je le cite
tous les matins se retrouver avec au
moins 16 patients sans lit pour les
accueillir c'est trop
j'arrête plus de 10 médecins de cette
équipe ont également annoncé leur départ
donc je parle d'aujourd'hui il a alerté
il y a un an il a
écrit et aujourd'hui il dit ça n'est
plus possible or vous nous annonce
effectivement un certain nombre de lits
armé 14000 lits votre annonce en
espérant que que ça n'aille pas jusque-
là hein par rapport au 5000 lits en RA
vous l'avez très bien dit donc avec
beaucoup de franchise pour armer des
lits en réa on désarme d'autres lit or
là on est dans un voilà dans un dans
dans un glissement c'est-à-dire que
finalement on déshabille Pierre pour
habiller Paul ou ou voilà
donc il y a une grande inquiétude il y a
eu des soins qui ont été programmés on a
entendu des personnes auditionnées
éminentes qui nous ont dit que il y
avait eu des pertes de chance pour des
patients des
patients victimes de cancer y compris en
cancérologie pédiatrique ENF c'est c'est
c'est terrible rien que de le dire donc
moi ma question monsieur le le ministre
c'est comment est-ce que aujourd'hui par
à la lumière de cette pandémie on on
crée et on donne de nouveaux moyens à
l'hôpital alors vous allez me dire mais
j'ai annoncé 15000 la création de 15000
emplois parce que pour armé des lit il
faut du personnel et on sait
pertinemment que là aussi ça fait défaut
contenu des politiques qui ont été mené
jusqu'à présent de
restriction budgétaire 15000
15000 donc emplois créés mais 15000
emplois créés il y en a la moitié qui
sont réellement créés et la moitié qui
était des postes vacants quelle mesure
vous vous prenez vous avez pris
pour faire en sorte que ces 15000
emplois soient effectifs et pour éviter
que les personnes que les personnels
soient épuisé parce que les personnels
sont à bout ils ont ils ont donné
vraiment beaucoup de leur personnes donc
ça c'est ma première question deuxè
deuxème question il y a beaucoup de mes
collègues qui ont dit qui et je je
partage qu'il y a une question aussi le
gouvernement a beaucoup miser sur la
communication on on a vu quand même
qu'elle était très cacophonique c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et et qui a pas
eu le le pour moi là ça nengage ça
m'engage en tant que en tant que
parlementaire il y a pas eu le langage
de vérité qui aurait été nécessaire
c'est-à-dire dire au français il y a une
pénurie de masque elle est réelle donc
on agit de telle façon notre stratégie
va être d'abord par exemple d'équiper
les personnels ensuite la population et
cetera et pas d'avoir ces approximations
scientifiques qui qui du coup porte un
coup après à toutes les toutes les
décisions qui sont prises donc à la lum
de ça je voudrais vous interroger sur le
fait que vous avez hier annoncé un
certain nombre de de mesures pour
protéger les personnes mais est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que ça rentre en
contradiction outre ce que mes collègues
ont dit sur l'association avec tous les
élus mais est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que ça rentre en contradiction avec le
fait que avec le décret d'Out qui a
sorti de la liste des personnes
vulnérables qui pouvaient prétendre au
télétravail un certain nombre de
personnes victimes de maladies comme
l'obésité le le les maladies
cardioovasculaires et cetera et cetera
celles-ci elles ont besoin d'être
protégées pourquoi elles sont sorties du
du décret troisème question c'est que
ces mesures autoritaires qui semblent
autoritaire qui sont bon font appel à la
responsabilité individuelle or on en est
tous conscient et vraiment la majorité
de nos concitoyennes et de nos
concitoyens en tout cas je le vois dans
mon département dans ma ville et cetera
les gestes barrières sont plutôt
euh adopté alors même enfin après il y a
des choses qui se passent dans des
événements mais je dis dans la la vie
quotidienne on va dire les gens on le
masque il font attention et cetera et
cetera donc c'est est-ce que je pense
qu'il faut faire attention parce que on
a tendance la tendance qui se dessine
quand même c'est aussi le risque d'avoir
une atteinte aux libertés et aux droits
et du coup ça m'amène à la question que
avait posé ma collègue madame Préville
c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai quand même le
sentiment au niveau des épades avec la
situation qui s'est passé qu'à partir du
moment où une personne est en perte
d'autonomie elle est ou alors voilà elle
est en perte d'autonomie elle est très
âgée et cetera on lui dénit s ses droits
la citoyenneté on choisit à sa place ça
nous est venu dans nos auditions or il y
a beaucoup de personnes en France encore
aujourd'hui et j'imagine ailleurs qui
sont pas morts du covid mais qui sont
morts de l'isolement donc restreindre
les les les droits de visite c'est tout
un un un problème enfin ma dernière
question c'est concernant le le vous
avez dit vous-même et je pense que vous
y êtes attentif parce que dans
l'émicycle vous avez réagi positivement
manque de médicament manque de de de de
réactif et cetera il y a une solution
qu'il faut à mon avis entrevoir dès
maintenant c'est pour être indépendant
au niveau de la France créer un pôle
public du médicament et de la recherche
au niveau national et au niveau européen
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie merci Muriel jourd merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais savoir comment
était organisé le service de veille au
ministère sur les risques pandémiques
internationaux par définition quel
personnel quel type de
personnel quel le type de renseignement
revue scientifique avis de
l'OMS ent des ambassades enfin vous
comprenez quel est le sens de ma
question et je souhaitais savoir
également si vous aviez analysé son
efficacité au vu de cette crise et
éventuellement si vous aviez envisagé de
modifier son
fonctionnement merci et Michel meunier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je voudrais vous repler du
premier tour des élections municipales
le 15 mars le samedi 14 mars le Premier
ministre ministre annonce la fermeture
des bars des restaurants et des autres
commerces non indispensables au
quotidien à partir de minuit le soir
même et le 15 mars le gouvernement ou le
président de la République c'est à vous
de nous le dire choisit de maintenir le
déroulement du premier tour des
élections municipales en faisant porter
sur les mairies la responsabilité et la
maîtrise des mesures sanitaire les
conditions dans lesquelles les
opérations de dépouillement du scrutin
ont été précisées inextré Miss dans le
courant du dimanche après-midi sont
quand même assez rambolesques à cette
époque je vous rappelle la la doctrine
du port du masque est celle selon
laquelle le masque est dédié aux
soignants et donc non obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de la population de toute
façon il y en a pas donc c'est le
système débrouille dans ces cas donc
sont apparus dans après le le premier
tour de ce scrutin des cas et il y a
même eu des des cès de scrutateur ma
question monsieur le ministre est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire qui a présidé à la
décision du maintien du premier tour des
élections municipales et est-ce que vous
avez eu un retour d'information sur les
répercussions de cette
élection ma deuxième question elle sera
aussi comme mont posé certains collègues
dont notre rapporteur Bernard jemier en
lien avec l'adhésion de nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et ce
besoin de confiance hier soir vous nous
avez communiqué à à
l'ensemble de la nation des des
recommandations et et les dernières
mesures et et ce matin un un comédien
français publiait sur son compte
Instagram un
panflet humoristique mais qui qui disait
en fin de compte ce que certaines et
certains disent de manière beaucoup plus
anonyme euh et qui euh traduit
une certaine méfiance ou en tout cas un
retrait hein c'était pour résumer si
vous ne savez pas donc c'est Nicolas
Bedos qui dit arrêtez tout les masques
les distanciations et vivons quit à en
mourir hein c'est à voilà donc c'est
c'est pas sur la forme d'expression qui
heureusement existe mais je me dis
est-ce qu'il y a pas dans la manière de
véhiculer les informations encore des
choses à remettre en cause ou à changer
à modifier parce que au-delà de cette
expression on sent bien que une bonne
partie des Français et des Français
n'adhèent pas totalement au gestes de
précaution merci de votre réponse merci
Monsieur le Ministre question précise
réponse
concise bien alors beaucoup de questions
ont été posées par la sénatrice boulet
esperoni euh il y a une inquiétude
d'ailleurs ça un peu la question madame
Menier à la fin il y a une inquiétude
des Français qui est partagée en fait je
pense que tous les Français sont
inquiets il y a ceux qui sont plus
inquiets aujourd'hui par la crise
sanitaire et ceux qui sont plus inquiets
par la crise économique sociale qui peut
les frapper et en fait je ne sais pas
quelle est la répartition de ces
inquiétudes certains sont inquiets par
les deux je connais pas de Français qui
soi objectivement inquiet par rien dans
la période que nous connaissons et je
tiens à rassurer les Français qui nous
regarderaient ce n'est pas un mal
français ça touche absolument tous les
pays qui ont été concernés et qui sont
concernés par le covid ça met en
question énormément de choses dans le
monde près de tris humains sur qu ont
été confinés c'était jamais arrivé et
nous avons perdu l'expertis des grandes
pandémies qui qui fracturent et qui et
qui tuent donc il faut pouvoir dans
cette inquiétude dans ce contexte
d'inquiétude partagé il faut avoir une
ligne de communication qui est clairire
j'entends les critiques que vous portez
je suis désolé si la communication
gouvernementale vous a paru manqué de
clarté par endroit nous avons organisé
une communication autour du ministère de
la Santé
les affaires sociales et des solidarités
du Premier ministre du président de la
République et puis les ministres sont
ont été amenés à participer à des
conférences de presse lorsqu'il
s'agissait des partis qui concernaient
leur périmètre ministériel jeai pas eu
le sentiment en tout cas que on se
marchait sur les pieds les uns les
autres en cette dans ce sujet dans ce
contexte là puisque c'était une volonté
du Président de la République que la
communication soit la plus claire et la
plus uniciste possible vous me posz une
question qui n'a ensuite qui n'a rien à
voir qui est sur les prescriptions
obligatoires de test alors est-ce que je
vous est-ce que je me pose la question
le matin en me rasant
oui je me dis nous avons mis en place là
des dispositifs nous avons réorienté
tous les barnomes pour pouvoir faire des
tests en en quantité pour tous les
publics prioritaires mais si jamais nous
étions en difficulté malgré cela et si
malgré le nombre de toute façon de cas
prioritaires devenait tel que nous
n'arrivions pas à faire face à à
l'objectif de la réduction des délais d
là qui se réduisent déjà à mon avis les
premiers chiffres seront seront de ce
point de vue-là bien meilleurs que les
derniers les prochains mais si jamais on
devait en arriver là oui enfin les pays
beaucoup de pays qui nous entourent ont
été ont été amenés à mettre en place des
systèmes de prescription obligatoire la
seule chose et pour être tout à fait
transparent dans ma façon de raisonner
avec vous c'est que si je demande à
quelqu'un d'aller chez son médecin avant
d'aller faire un test on va se prendre
globalement avec les épidémies les viros
qui arrivent 24 à 36 he dans la vue
avant que la personne puisse avoir son
puisse commencer imaginer faire tester
donc je je voilà j'étais sûr de
l'efficacité VO je je concerte je
consulte et pour l'instant on en est pas
là mais je s'il fallait le faire on le
ferait vous me posez la question du du
du covid au long cours j'ai déjà dit
tout ce que je savais sur le sujet y
compris non c'était à l'Assemblée
nationale
pardonnez-moi il y a des gens qui font
des formes graves de covid qui vont en
réanimation qui on des troubles
respiratoires avec des scanners
thoraciques qui montrent des lésions de
fibrose avec des séquelles respiratoires
potentiellement à au long court ces
gens-là sont mis en maladie
professionnelle avec un taux
d'invalidité et ils sont suivis en
pneumologie pour les C quel des dégâts
pulmonaires et respiratoires des virus
il y a des gens qui font des formes qui
sont pas forcément graves
symptommatiques en tout cas qui vont pas
forcément en réa ou à l'hôpital et qui
conservent à l'issue de le leur maladie
une fatigue des mauxs de tête des
crampes des courbatures parfois une
perte d'appétit des vertiges beaucoup de
symptômes qui sont difficiles à
rassembler sous une sealele étiquette
mais qui sont bien ressentis par ceux
qui les ont certains décrivent que ça
peut durer 2 semaines d'autres pendant 2
mois et certains disent qu'ils ne les
ont pas perdu des mois après les
médecins travaillent euh avec la
recherche et notamment la recherche
clinique pour essayer de comprendre ce
quelle est la nature de ces symptômes et
ce qui a pu les provoquer j'ai vu
différentes hypothèses dans lesquels je
ne me risquerai pas ici mais qui font
l'objet de protocole d'étude et des
filières de prise en charge de ces
patients sont organisés dans des centres
spécialisés pour essayer d'apporter des
réponses ce que je sais c'est que ces
personnes-là quand on fait des épreuves
fonctionnelles respiratoires lorsqu'on
fait des scanners pulmonaires ou des
examen cardiaque poussé n'ont pas de de
cause anatomique identifié et pour
autant ils se sentent dispnay et ce donc
ça fait partie des mystères de ce virus
un mystère est là pour être élucidé je
voudrais apporter une réponse à ces
personnes la plus rapide et la plus
satisfaisante possible et trouver
surtout un moyen de les soulager à date
je ne je ne peux pas encore vous
répondre je crois pas qu'il y ait enfin
on est très loin d'un consensus
scientifique en la question les risques
de rechute madame la sénatrice ce que je
sais c'est vous le savez aussi c'est
qu'il eu quelques cas qui ont été
emblématiques puisqu'ils ont fait la une
de la presse scientifique mondiale de
personnes qui étaient immunisé et qui
ont pourtant réattrapé le virus quand
quand les cas qui arrivent sont
emblématiques et que vous avez des
millions et des millions de cas on peut
quand même
considérer raisonnablement qu' y a pas
de raison de rechoper le covid quand
vous l'avez chopé une première fois
maintenant on a peu de recul est-ce que
les anticorps ils vont durer 6 mois ou 1
an ou 2 ans j'en sais rien je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas je peux je
peux pas vous le dire faut toujours se
méfier et la présence d'anticorps ne
signe pas forcément des alors là on sait
que le anticorps sont protecteurs mais
pour vous dire il faut pas qu'on soit
trop empressé avant de avant de d'acter
des choses l'histoire du VIH elle a été
marquée par cette terrible histoire des
gens chez qui ont identifié des
anticorps ils étaient donc séropositifs
et et les médecins leur disaient à
l'époque on connaissait pas le sida et
leur disait vous êtes immunisé contre le
sida alors qu'en réalité ceux qui
avaient des anticorps étaient malades
c'est pas du tout le cas avec le covid
je rassure tout le monde mais c'est pour
vous dire que le fait d'avoir des
anticorps n'est pas forcément en en soi
euh avec si peu de recul un élément
déterminant pour la suite de sa vie mais
mais c'està dire que ça ne protège pas
forcément mais on a quand même des
indices qui laissent à penser que si
voilà plutôt
optimiste rapidement les tests sont
gratuits pour la population encore une
fois ils sont gratuits pour tous pour la
population française le prix du test
c'est 55 € pour une PCR c'est un prix
qui permet aux biologistes je l'ai déjà
dit d'investir et d'acheter des
plateformes PCR c'est normal qu'il y ait
un prix qui sinon les biologistes ne
s'équipent pas nanticipe pas ne prévoit
pas et on n'a pas c test télétravail oui
oui oui tout à fait d'accord et si vous
voulez mener un travail législatif sur
la question ça peut être très
intéressant madame Cohen le la difficile
turnover de la médecine d'urgence déjà
hors crise c'est compliqué la médecine
d'urgence et beaucoup de médecins
urgentistes passionnés par leur
profession finissent par aller faire
d'autres types d'exercices de la
médecine parce que c'est dur les
urgences c'est dur la médecine d'urgence
passer ces nuits et ces journées à
chercher des places dans les à gérer le
stress parfois à se sentir pas forcément
en sécurité avec une telle polyvalence
et un tel nombre de patients je me
souviens de mes dernières gardes aux
urgences comme je médecin ou me de
confier à 18h la liste des des je sais
pas des 20 patients dont je devais déjà
m'occuper avec un nouveau patient qui
arrive toutes les 5 minutes c'est un
métier stressant merci
merci s'il vous plaît oui mais les
questions étaient monsieur le sénateur
je ve bien répondre plus rapidement que
les questions m'ont été posées paré 8
minutes j'en suis à une minute de
réponse les anecdotes nous passionnent
mais peut-être que nous pourrions
répondre bon et puis le seggure le
seggure soutient très fortement
l'hôpital et vous aurez l'occasion dans
le PLFSS de voter des mesures m de
soutien des créations de postes
ouvertures de lit des réouvertures de
lit la reprise de dett de
l'investissement hospitalier et 8
milliards d'euros versé aux salariés
dont 80 et quelques pour sont des femmes
souspayées pour le boulot qu'ell faisait
et vous allez j'espère et j'en suis
certain voter ces mesures au moins
celle-ci dans le pfss sur la la pénurie
vis-à-vis de la doctrine là je je veux
bien répondre en 30 secondes mais vous
allez me reposer la question si je 30
secondes monsieur le le vice-président
sur la peinerie versus doctrine des
masques je ne fais pas de lien entre la
p de masque et la doctrine d'utilisation
des masques je l'ai déjà dit je le redis
je ne fais pas le lien le CDC européenne
qui n'avait pas géré des stocks de
masques n'a pas fait le lien non plus
qui a fait la même doctrine l'OMS qui
n'avait pas géré de stock de masque a
fait la même
doctrine si je reprends 2 secondes mais
vous connaissez ça presque mieux que moi
si ce n'est mieux parce que vous avez
posé la question à tout le monde mais
l'OMS quand même le 6 avril 2020 alors
qu'on produisait déjà des masques grand
publics dans ses orientations
provisoires l'OMS déconseiller encore le
6 avril 2020 déconseiller expressément
le port généralisé du masque considérant
que ce serit contre-productif je les
cite aucune donnée ne montre
actuellement le port du masque pour les
personnes en bonne santé dans les
espaces collectives y compris s'il est
généralisé pour prévenir les infections
par des par des virus respiratoire le
port du masque médical dans les espaces
collectifs peut créer un faux sentiment
de sécurité et amener à négliger
d'autres mesures essentielles comme j
des mains et cetera et cetera par ce que
j'ai répété à l'envie j'ai répété ça à
l'envie j'ai dit les recommandations de
l'OMS les recommandations de le CDC les
recommandations de toutes les instances
scientifiques dont on dispose et tous
les vieux grimoirs du ministère de la
Santé qui regorgent d'études sur la
grippe et sur la grippe H1N1 entre 2009
et 2020 pter vers la même doctrine donc
je le dis très clairement je suis arrivé
comme ministre il n'y avait plus enfin
le mal était fait en matière de stock de
masque donc si j'avais dû dire au
français on aurait dû vous donner des
masques mais on en a pas je l'aurait
dit il y a deux choses qui sont
différentes la doctrine et le le et le
stock en l'occurrence on navait pas un
stock suffisant ne serait-ce que pour
protéger les soignants donc je l'aurais
dit je l'aurais dit bon sur la doctrine
elle est inspirée je vous le disais des
recommandations scientifiques françaises
européennes international OMS et nous
avons évolué avant que celle-ci évolue
parce que l'OMS a mis du temps pour
bouger c'était je crois le 4 ou 5 juin
que l'OMS a considéré que le masque
grand public pouvait sen faire consensus
scientifique être intéressant ça faisait
très longtemps Bell lurette qu'on
produisait des masques des masques grand
public je comprends parfaitement
je veux pas donner l'impression d'être
au-dessus de la polémique je comprends
parfaitement et je vous assure que j'ai
vécu la crise et je l'ai traversé avec
ce sujet là en
permanence est-ce que je regrette qu'on
n pas eu le stock de masque suffisant
pour protéger les soignants les hôpitaux
les médecins et ce oui évidemment
évidemment est-ce que si j'avais eu 2
milliards de masques en stock on en
aurait distribué à la population je
honnêtement sur la base des
recommandations dont on dispose je ne
vois pas pourquoi on le fait par exemple
on avait des gants on aurait pu
distribuer des gants au gens on savait
pas on av'ait pas la conviction que le
gants n'était pas a priori le gants
n'est pas protecteur et de fait le gants
n'est pas protecteur mais imaginons
qu'on soit rendu compte en cours de la
crise que le gants était protecteur vous
nous auriez dit pourquoi vous avez pas
distribué les gants dire on sait qu'un
outil est utile lorsqu'on a prouvé son
utilité jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
n'y avait pas de passage aérosol du
virus coronavirus ce que nous disaient
tous les scientifiques du monde entier
et donc le port du masque en population
générale ne s'imposait pas et n'était
même pas forcément recommandé d'après
les REC de de la chaise et j'ai dit
d'ailleurs même très très tôt je crois
ma deuxième conférence de presse qu'il
aurait une utilité si au moins 60 % de
la population le portait continuellement
et de la bonne manière voilà par
ailleurs encore une fois ça ne change
rien au fait qu'on avait pas assez de
masque pour protéger correctement les
soignants dans les hôpitaux en ville et
que ça ça ça a été extrême extrêmement
dur à
gérer si si je l'ai dit Madame aussi
aussi je l'ai dit j'ai même parlé de de
gestion en bon père de famille pour
éviter de tomber à zéro au niveau des
stocks vous me posez la question du du
décret sur les personnes vulnérables ce
décret vise à éviter avant tout la
désinsertion professionnelle de
plusieurs millions de personnes qui sont
en qui étai en activité partielle depuis
des mois il y a un avis du Haut conseil
de santé publique du 19 juin qui
autorise la fin de l'activité partielle
prévue au 1er septembre on peut faire
évoluer les choses en fonction de la
circulation du virus évidemment que la
priorité reste la protection des plus
fragiles mais ce risque de désinsertion
professionnelle est réel j'ai concerté
moi-même les fédérations de d'usagers et
pour pouvoir déterminer aussi avec eux
des listes de maladies donnant lieu à la
la mise en activité partielle
persistante et par ailleurs un médecin
peut sur ordonnance continuer de
déclarer son son patient comme étant
trop trop à risque pour aller au travail
et on favorise le télétravail dans tous
les cas pour Madame Jourdin
l'organisation de la veille
sanitaire pardond Jourda pardon Jourda
pardon madame Jourda madame la sénatrice
pardon sur la
question sur la question experti
sanitaire
euh le Corus qui est le la cellule en
charge ce qu'on appelle c'est le centre
opérationnel chargé de la réception de
la gestion des alertes sanitaires et la
coordination des acteurs de l'expertise
sanitaire et certifié ISO il a une
composition que je peux vous donner dans
le détail peut-être pas là parce que
sinon je vais me faire rappeler à juste
titre à l'ordre mais vous avez beaucoup
de partenaires qui sont également
mobilisés au-delà du au-delà du Corus de
la sous-direction il y a les ARS il y a
l'agence de sécurité sanitaire nationale
comme la NSM le FS l'Agence de
biomédecine l'Inca l'ancest l'IRSN enfin
vous avez toute une sorte un panel une
flopée d'agences et de structures qui
participe à la veille et la sécurité
sanitaire par catégorie par spécificité
comportant les meilleurs experts est-ce
que il faut changer cette organisation
de la veille sanitaire je crois qu'elle
a fonctionné contamine monjois loise des
choses qui ont été identifiées tout de
suite très vite donc elle a pu montrer
qu'elle était fonctionnelle mais ça fera
partie du rétexte général de toute façon
sur les mun MP premier tour des
municipales qui a décidé c'est le
politique qui décide jamais on n'est pas
dans un biopouvoir donc toute décision a
été
prise par les responsables politiques le
conseil scientifique a été consulté deux
fois le 12 mars et le 14 mars les deux
avis sont publics et je peux vous dire
soucèrement que face au conseil
scientifique je leur ai dit la phrase
suivante n'internalisez pas la
contrainte
politique ne vous préoccupez pas de
savoir si c'est compliqué ou non
d'annuler une
élection est-ce que l'annulation du
premier tour de l'élection municipale
vous semble nécessaire utile ou non le
12 mars l'avis dit il faut pas annuler
les élections le 14 mars 2 jours plus
tard je redemande contenu de l'évolution
de la situation sanitaire la réponse du
Conseil scientifique est la même de
points ouvr les guillemets l'exercice de
la démocratie garantie par la sécurité
sanitaire du vote gagne à être préservé
afin que la population conserve dans la
durée une confiance les élections du
premier tour des municipales se sont
déroulé dans des conditions
particulières avec de la distanciation
sociale respect des gestes barrières gel
hydroalcoolique stylo et cetera et
cetera il y a eu des études
intéressantes qui n'ont pas montrer me
semble-t-il mais je suis souscement donc
le me semble-t-il je n'aime pas le
prononcer mais que il n'y avait pas eu
un très fort en tout cas il n'y avait
pas eu un impact mesurable à la suite à
la suite de cela les scientifiques dans
les dans les mois qui viendront
publieront des données je pense plus
affinées sur sur sur la question et puis
sur le grand sujet presque philosophique
de savoir s'il faut vivre quit à en
mourir si c'était je pourrais comprendre
ce type de réflexion c'est l'orter des
conséquences sur sa seule
santé moi on peut pas imposer aux gens
de prendre soin d'eux malgré eux mais on
peut imposer aux gens de prendre soin
des autres malgré
eux la ceinture de sécurité
dans une voiture n pas que pour but de
protéger le conducteur elle a pour but
aussi de protéger les autres
l'hygiénisme est une discipline complexe
qui est peuplé de mise en garde
d'injonction relise
Camu reliser Camu on rien inventé le
confinement
d'or le la lassitude qui gagne la
population semaine après semaine mois
après
mois c'est la tentation de certains de
se dire puis tant pis
et puis certains commencent à dire que
finalement c'est des personnes âgées que
c'est peut-être moins grave on n'est pas
dans soleil vert on est dans la société
française on est dans le pays des
Lumières on protège les gens qui sont
vulnérables peu importe leur âge peu
importe les facteurs de risque sanitair
qu'ils ont ce n'est pas à nous ce n'est
pas à moi de décider qui mérite d'être
protégé et qui peut mourir pour protéger
les autres c'est je veux dire c'est une
question qui est essentiel nous avons
fait le choix le président de la
République a été très clair avec le quoi
qu'il en coûte de protéger la vie et
d'assurer la SC sécurité é es français
et j'ajoute pour ceux qui seraient
réservés sur la question
d'intergénérationnalité question à
laquelle je crois fondamentalement sinon
je n'aurais pas fait de la neurologie je
n'aurais pas commencé ma carrière en
travaillant en épade comme re
soignant j'ajoute que par ailleurs 30 %
des malades quasiment un malade sur 3
admis en RA est un malade qui n'a pas
même pas 65
ans donc voilà vivre quitte à en mourir
c'est une phrase à l'emportepièce qu'on
peut lancer sur un blog sur un compte
Instagram on peut faire un effet de
tribune ou c'est peut-être une façon un
exutoire personnel je pense que dans la
période on doit être extrêmement
attentif surtout quand on est on fait on
a beaucoup d'écoute autour de soi à
notre façon de nous exprimer et au
message que nous véhiculons une société
qui déciderait de faire l'impasse sur
ses vieux une société qui déciderait de
faire l'impasse sur ces fragiles sur ces
précaires et de faire l'impasse sur des
morts évitables ce n'est pas une société
dans laquelle j'ai été éduqué élevé et
dans laquelle j'ai envie de d'éduquer
mes enfants merci Jean-François rappin
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre vous avez votre expérience de
neurologue j'ai mon expérience de
médecin généraliste et je je vais vous
poser plusieurs questions sur sur la
pratique actuelle on va pas trop revenir
enfin j'y reviendrai un petit peu sur
sur l'antériorité mais en tout cas sur
l'actuel vous avez annoncé à plusieurs
reprises et on l'a
entendu un objectif alors je sais pas si
c'est un objectif mais on entendait
régulièrement le chiffre de 700000 tests
par semaine qui est peut-être un chiffre
d'efficacité qui est un chiffre
peut-être aussi de de de capacité
d'absorption des des tests en tout cas
aujourd'hui on est à 1 milliion1 1002 en
fonction des 13 même ça monte encore euh
donc je voudrais savoir d'abord si le
chiffre de 700000 pour vous était un
chiffre euh scientifique ou un chiffre
technique par rapport à la capacité
d'absorption et la façon dont
aujourd'hui on pourrait résorber
finalement cet excédent parce que si
700000 était le chiffre de capacité
d'absorption passer euh quasiment au
double euh provoque untit provoque les
problèmes qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui
dans les problèmes qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui c'est ma deuxième question
il y en a un qui est particulier je
dirais la médecine générale c'est celui
de l'arrêt de travail on est confronté
aujourd'hui à une situation où on a
l'impression parfois de mettre les gens
en arrêt de travail pour rien
c'est-à-dire ils sont qu'à contact euh
ils sont dans une situation où ils ne
peuvent pas faire de télétravail et on
les met en arrêt de travail en attendant
le test parce que les délais sont longs
donc je pense qu'il y a là un sujet il y
a peut-être une expertise à faire sur le
nombre d'arrêts de travail mais en tout
cas il y a un vrai sujet un sujet pour
l'entreprise mais un sujet aussi pour le
patient parce que vous savez monsieur le
ministre que au mois de juillet le délai
de carence a été finalement remis en
place et aujourd'hui sur des courts
arrêts de travail les gens sont en arrêt
3 qu jours en attendant d'avoir le test
et c'est un vrai sujet financier pour
eux tout au moins pour les pour les
petits salaires donc je j'implore votre
attention sur ce sujet qui est un vrai
sujet à la fois médical mais aussi euh
social le 3è point il vient peut-être
sur la rétrospective il est peut-être un
petit peu plus agressif mais en tout cas
il nécessite aussi de votre part une
réponse le président de la République
nous a dit dans une très belle
déclaration c'est la guerre sauf que
hier madame la ministre madame Busin
madame l'ex-ministre de la santé nous
explique et en fin d'intervention
finalement et de façon un peu impromptue
que santé publique France a failli euh
not notamment sur les stocks et pas
seulement les stocks de masque puisque
on lui a fait redire ce qu'elle avait de
façon un
peu discrète annoncé à l'Assemblée
nationale que sur d'autres produits nous
avions des défaillances extrêmes et
qu'il était temps de de les de les
remettre de les remettre en place donc
la guerre on l'a commencé avec un très
beau char d'assaut qui s'appelle la
santé publique mais il n'a pas été
chargé en obus donc je suppose que si
c'était la guerre le le militaire en
charge de mettre les obus dans le char
d'assaut aujourd'hui il il serait en
tout cas recherché identifié pour savoir
qui il est et ce qui s'est passé et
aujourd'hui on aimerait bien savoir si
vous avez mené une une enquête interne
au sein de santé publique France pour
savoir finalement où sont les
responsabilités qui sont portés
aujourd'hui sur le fait que dans
diverses matières entre autres les les
masques bien sûr aujourd'hui peut-être
les gants et de nombreux produits
pharmaceutiques il y avait des manques
voire des péremptions euh atteindre
depuis depuis longtemps voilà Monsieur
le Ministre merci
annieigimau merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre plusieurs points le
premier point vous avez rendu hommage et
reconnaissance aux soignants et je crois
qu'on est vraiment tous avec vous bien
sûr dans cette reconnaissance mais
pensez-vous que le décret que vous avez
pris sur la reconnaissance de la maladie
professionnelle en pensant que les seuls
les soignants qui avaient été oxygénés
auraient cette
reconnaissance soit vraiment une
reconnaissance justement des soignants
et et est-ce que vous allez rendre un
avis positif au Conseil de la sécurité
de la santé publique pour le
remplacement éventuel d'un soignant même
s'il est testé covid asymptomatique il
devrait rester au travail il y a eu
toutes cette polémique j'aimerais avoir
votre avis le deuxième point alors nous
sommes bien sûr par rapport à vos
annonces hier je vais pas revenir sur ce
que disait Laurence Cohen votre
mobilisation et la mobilisation de tout
le ministère euh mais souvent moi je
regarde goû France covid parce que on a
besoin de répondre aux questions les les
parlementaires on est beaucoup beaucoup
questionné j'ai eu par exemple plein de
ce matin d'appel pour les piscines
est-ce que les piscines sont fermées
est-ce que c'est une salle de sport euh
les taxis aussi qui ont pas de masque
souvent dans les taxis parce qu'ils ont
un plexiglace mais certains ont pas de
plexiglace enfin il y a plein de de
question comme ça et aujourd'hui coup
France n'est toujours pas à jour de vos
annonces d'hier on est toujours sur le
17 septembre et et c'est vrai que c'est
aussi un un problème trème question moi
je reviens sur ce que disait mon
collègue précédent sur la gestion des
masques par santé publique France j'ai
eu l'occasion hier de poser la même
question à Madame Buzin euh la l'étude
l'expertise qui est fait début 2018
95 % des médicaments sont à out et sur
les 700 millions de masques il en reste
plus que 4
milli let qui part du directeur de santé
publique France au DGS le DGS lui répond
le 30 octobre alors que la lettre est du
6 septembre je crois de commander 50
millions de masqu et 50 millions autres
si le budgjet le permet et tout ça sans
avoir fait référence ou avoir transmis
ni le DGS ni le directeur de santé
publique France à la ministre est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est normal 95 % des
médicaments donc là il y a un véritable
problème et moi je je partage enfin je
le redis la crédibilité de l'État et de
l'organisation de l'État est posée parce
que quand je vois ce que fait l'état en
17 ans de maire sur les maires qui
respectent pas telle et telle chose je
me demande quand même comment on peut
pas faire une enquête et comment il y a
pas des sanction il y a bien des choses
la crédibilité elle est aussi dans la
reconnaissance qui a eu pénurie par
parce que parce que parce que 4è point
vous avez dit il faut je vais gérer la
crise aujourd'hui et
demain mais le questionnement entre
l'hôpital privé et l'hôpital public
souvent on nous pose des questions les
citoyens pourquoi l'Hôpital Privé
n'accepte pas tous les malades non covid
ou les c'est la question qu'on nous pose
et pourquoi l'hôpital
public aujourd'hui quelle est votre
position sur cette articulation hôpital
privé hôpital public et par rapport à
l'hôpital public pourquoi on a encore
des médecins qui disent bah aujourd'hui
j'ai encore 16 personnes je trouve pas
de place 16 personnes en hospitalisation
d'urgence je trouve pas de place est-ce
que on est aussi mal préparé que que
l'autrefis enfin ma dernière question
c'est sur la question justement de
l'organisation elle-même de l'État la
question que j'ai posé aussi madame
Buzin lors de son audition à l'Assemblée
nationale elle a fait la réflexion nous
l'a refait hier elle nous l'a détaillé
qu'il faudrait
peut-êtreevoir le système et créer une
agence qui serait une agence de
l'ensemble des pandémies qu'ell soi
sanitaire environnemental ou
accidentelle et je voulais avoir aussi
votre avis sur ce sur cette
proposition merci David
assouine merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais commencer
aussi euh comme ma collègue Cohen par
vous dire que
euh ce qui apparaît encore dans cette
audition mais on vous a vu depuis le
début de la crise vous parlez avec la la
bonne foi de celui qui s'est démené et
on l'a vu que vous êtes
démené comme personne pour faire face à
une
crise forte inattendue exceptionnelle et
cetera et
donc vous vous finalement euh vous vous
enfermez dans cette bonne foi et cette
conviction là nous sommes dans une
commission d'enquête qui essae de voir
que malgré tout cette bonne foi il y a
eu des problèmes pour pouvoir les
corriger et le malaise c'est que vous ne
reconnaissez aucun problème et et et et
et par exemple vous vous enté sur
quelque chose qui est maintenant
installé pour tout le monde c'est que il
y a eu la
facilité même si vous vous abritez
derrière l'OMS vous n'avez pas
interrogé
cette cette
question effectivement validée par l'OMS
sur la question des masques grand public
parce que ça vous arrangeait parce que
comme il n y avait pas de masque et bien
quand l'OM vous avez été chercher même
chez
l'OMS le fait que une ministre est venue
nous expliquer c'était même dangereux de
les porter et que c'était
contreproductif c'est c'est c'est c'est
les fait tout le monde sait que
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de masque qu'on a expliqué qu'il
n'en fallait pas et ou sinon on peut pas
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui on dis à tout
le monde de porter des masques et que le
fait que deux personnes portent un
masque et ben bien entendu ça réduit les
risques et dans les pays asiatiques ça
fait bien longtemps que cette doctrine
est installée et qu'on aurait pu dire
tiens c'est bizarre l'OMS peut-être dit
ça mais dans les pays asiatiques il font
autrement alors qu'ils sont en proie à
ces problèmes souvent et bien avant nous
et donc pourquoi ils le font vous vous
êtes contenté d'expliquer et ça vous
pouvez le reconnaître parce que le
problème c'est la confiance par rapport
à ce que dit la parole publique pour
faire face à une crise pour l'ensemble
des citoyens et c'est là que j'en viens
à mes questions euh euh actuel c'est un
peu la même chose euh quand il y a un
conseil de défense où on nous annonce
que le président va faire des annonces
fortes c'était la semaine dernière et
que finalement on se rend parce qu'on
voit bien que le virus circule et qu'il
faut réagir fortement donc on sait qu'il
y a une exponentielle il y a déjà une
dizaines de jours et puis il n'y a pas
d'annonce il y a juste l'annonce que les
préfets vont agir et vont prendre des
mesures parce qu'il faut les
localiser et hier on
apprend qu'il y a un certain nombre de
mesures notamment à Marseille et à Paris
en Guadeloupe et cetera et vous dites on
a concerté bon non non la mère de Paris
on l'a appelé 1 heure avant et elle
n'est pas d'accord avec la mesure elle
est d'accord qu'il faut des mesures et
je pense qu'à Marseille ça doit être le
cas bien entendu qu'il faut deses mesure
mais celles qui sont proposées donc la
concrétisation c'est là que la
concertation doit être avec avec les
élus locaux et ce souci que ce soit
compris en disant les choses tel qu'ell
et en trouvant les bonnes mesures on
voit encore quelque chose de décousu il
y a aucune annonce du
Président on va dire au préfet donc il
va une concertation d'une semaine non
c'est 1 heure avant et on peut se dire
par exemple sur la question des bars les
ferm à 10h c'est quand même atteindre du
point de vue économique une profession
qui est déjà dans une situation
catastrophique on peut se dire que entre
la situation où il suffit de s'asseoir à
une terrasse pour ne plus avoir à porter
le masque pour ne plus avoir à respecter
aucune distanciation sociale et donc des
attroupements énormes dans tous les
cafés et les restaurants entre ça et
fermé il y a peut-être une mesure qui
est de dire qu' en dehors du moment où
on boit on doit porter le masque y
compris sur les terrasses il y a
peut-être ça et peut-être qu'un élu peut
vous le dire si vous l'écoutez avant
d'annoncer donc la concertation encore
une fois dans une certaine panique d'une
situation qui est en train de monter et
bien elle est juste réduit à euh euh pas
grand-chose en gros je veux conclure par
une question mais qui a aussi un
conseil je pense même dans les crises de
ce type que dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont telles qu'ell se pose à
vous qui devez prendre des décisions aux
Français et plus productif pour
entraîner la nation à affronter une
telle crise que toutes les euh euh les
les choses qu'on cache un peu
c'est clair que vous êtes confronté
aujourd'hui à la question
suivante il y a un virus qui circule de
façon exponentielle ça ressemble à ce
qui se passait au mois de mars la mesure
que vous avez pris alors était radicale
le
confinement vous savez que vous ne
pouvez pas le faire comme ça aujourd'hui
sans mettre à bas l'économie pouvez le
dire au français donc il y a des
activités économiques on va prendre un
peu plus de risque on va aller
travailler on va prendre des transports
on va laisser les écoles ouvertes pour
que les gens puissent aller travailler
dites-le que c'est pour ça que vous
reconfinez
pas mais quand il s'agit de
s'amuser de pas être dans l'activité
économique aller au bar et cetera là on
fait n'importe quoi vous vous vous tapez
et ça les Français le sentent qu'il y a
de l'incohérence dites les choses et
vous entraînerez la nation merci merci
la derni dernière question Marie-Pierre
de la
Gonterie merci monsieur le Président
vous l'avez compris cette commission
d'enquête veut aussi identifier les
points qui permettrai sans doute en
étant amélioré de de mieux préparer
l'appareil d'État et l'appareil
sanitaire à à d'éventuelles difficultés
il se trouve d'ailleurs que les
difficultés nous les revivons
aujourd'hui donc je je voudrais vous
interroger sur les relations de l'État
et donc évidemment les vôtres mais pas
que avec les ARS nous avons auditionné
car vous avez sans doute vu que le choix
de cette commission a été de d'entendre
d'abord les acteurs qu'on peut qualifier
guillemets de terrain avant de de de de
de parler aux responsables d'entendre
les responsables nationaux nous avons
entendu les les directeurs des
directeurs d'Ars et euh ce don ce qu'il
est ressorti de ces auditions je vais
pas vous égrainer nous n'avons plus le
temps il est tard c'est que de
nombreuses alertes avaient été remontées
et je prends bien la période à partir de
laquelle vous êtes ministre hein euh de
nombreuses alertes avaient été avaient
été adressées euh auprès du du ministère
donc leur interlocuteur naturel étant le
directeur général de de la santé et euh
certains ARS ayant constaté que leur
signalement était sans réponse d'autant
que euh il y avait je me trompe
peut-être mais une une réunion
téléphonique tous les soirs euh et que
lors de cette réunion téléphonique tout
tous les ARS étaient présents et que
donc il n'y avait pas de possibilité de
d'appréhension différenciée selon les
territoires donc sur ce point-là est-ce
que sans aller jusqu'à vous suggérer de
d'autocritique ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet mais est-ce que vous avez bien
identifier des pistes d'amélioration
dans la façon dont vous avez pu
travailler avec les ARS notamment en
l'illustrant avec la question des
transfert on a déjà eu l'occasion ici
d'évoquer les transferts de malades qui
ont pu être effectués en France ou à
l'étranger et euh un ARS nous a euh nous
a relaté un incident qui s'est produit
le 6 avril concernant le transfert de
patients en Autriche où euh alors que
euh le le l'avion était dors et déjà
présent je résume euh sur instruction du
cabinet du ministre il avait été décidé
d'arrêter euh le transfert et que euh
étant soumis au pouvoir hiérarchique euh
ces instructions ont été appliquées sans
que l'on sache si la santé des patients
pouvait être mis en D par cette décision
alors vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous avez noté cette phrase euh vous
avez dit je ne crois pas que les ARS
soit complètement abruti c'était une
façon un peu informelle j'ai bien
compris j'ai bien compris non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que vous vous
vous avez évoqué par cette formule le
fait que vous considériez qu'ils avaient
une réelle compétence donc comment
expliquez-vous que votre cabinet à ce
moment-là est décidé de stopper un
transfert alors même que les malades
étaient au au pied au pied de de l'avion
enfin dernière chose on en parle peu
mais la situation dans les université se
dégrade de manière
considérable quelles sont les
instructions précises enfin je dire
efficace que vous avez adressé vous ou
le gouvernement mais bon dans ce domaine
et enfin je je pense que votre mémoire
vous vous fait des tours parce que j'ai
retrouvé une un propos vous avez pu
tenir vous-même sur les masques sur les
stocks de FFP2 lors d'une conférence de
presse en février où vous avez indiqué
nous disposons de de stock stratégiqu
dans les hôpitaux dans un très grand
nombre de cabinets liméux et dans un
grand nombre de services de l'État qui
nous permettent de faire face à la
demande il n'y a donc aucun problème
d'accès à ces masques pour toutes celles
et ceux qui en ont besoin
donc c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
faut être très attentif à à à tous ces
propos qui ont été tenus merci monsieur
le Président merci ben écoutez c'était
la dernière question donc nous vous
écoutons pour vos dernières réponses je
vais peut-être démarrer par la fin et
commencer par répondre à la sénatrice
Marie-Pierre de la
Gonterie parce que j'ai été très
attentif au travail des agences
régionales de santé et parce que comme
vous l'avez souligné nous avons eu des
discussion quasi quotidienne avec
l'ensemble des agences j'ai pu m'assurer
du travail qui était effectué par les
unes et les autres dans les différentes
situations qui étaient rencontré vous
avez auditionné parmi ceux que vous avez
auditionné un directeur général de
l'agence régionale de santé qui a été
démis en conseil des ministres de ses
fonctions qui a fait une saisine
d'ailleurs de la justice pour contester
les conditions de sa démission de sa de
de de sa du fait qu'il soit démis de ses
fonctions madame de La gterie si ce
directeur général a été démis de ses
fonctions c'est parce que justement j'ai
été attentif à la situation de l'action
de chaque direction d'Ars dans chaque
territoire concerné et que certes le
grand test a été la région qui a été le
plus percuté et le plus tôt par la crise
épidémique
mais je vous invite à à consulter
l'ensemble des élus quel que soit le
bord
politique de la région vous verrez que
lorsque je me suis entretenu avec les
élus il n'y avait un consensus sur les
dysfonctionnements hélas hélas sur les
dysfonctionnements et donc je n'ai pas à
considérer pardonnez-moi que ce
directeur d'agence régionale de santé
dans le constat qui fait de l'action que
nous avons mené l'emporte sur l'ensemble
des autres directeurs plus
l'administration centrale plus mes
services ministériels et moi-même
c'était pas l'Autriche madame la
sénatrice était la République Tcheque il
y avait des transferts des évacuations
sanitaires de six patients qui étaient
anticipés pour la République tchèque
contte tenu de la saturation vous savez
à ce jour à cette période là j'étis
appelé à peu près plusieurs fois par
jour en tout cas par des élus de la
région Grand Est des maires présidents
de département ou des directions
d'établissement qui me suppliaient qui
me demandaient légitimement d'activer
tous les réseaux d'évacuation sanitaire
qu'on pouvait évacuer parce qu'ils
sentaient la pression la vague montait
et qu'ils avaient légitimement très peur
tout bord politique conf je crois que
j'étais à peu près tout
su la République tchèque était une
destination éloignée pour des malades et
le jour où le transfert était organisé
la vague épidémique avait commencé à
baisser de façon
sensible le nombre de patients admis
dans les réanimations de la région
avaiit commencé depuis quelques temps à
refluer et j'ai été contacté par des
équipes sur place me disant qu'il
trouvait abérrant d'aller muter
d'envoyer par hélicoptère des patients
en République tchèque où il se
réveilleraiit un jour hors du coma très
loin de chez eux très loin de leur
famille alors même qu'il y avait
désormais des places vacantes dans les
hôpitaux environnants madame la
sénatrice je suis certain je suis même
sûr qu'à ma place vous auriez pris
exactement la même décision qui
consistait à annuler le transfert
sanitaire ah ben j'en suis sûr j'en suis
sûr tout le monde ici prendrait la même
décision que cette décision soit
contestée par le directeur me conforte
dans la décision qui a pu être prise
hélas de nous séparer d'un directeur en
pleine crise ce qui était pas une
décision facile sur la question des
universités pardon je je je suis
souscerment je ne suis pas je ne veux
pas sortir de mes compétences sanitaires
et parce que vous avez insisté sur le la
nécessité d'avoir une communication
gouvernementale harmonieuse je je
préfère renvoyer à la ministre en charge
des universités les questions évidemment
des protocoles sanitaires qui sont qui
existent au niveau national qui sont
très claires dont l'application
territoriale par certains rectorats
peut-être éventuellement renforcé et Don
l'application territoriale par certaines
écoles ou universités peut-être encore
renforcé bon tout ça nécessite
l'expertise de la Ministre en
charge sur les les chiffres techniques
pour les tests très
rapide très rapidement sur les chiffres
des sur les chiffres des tests capacité
PCR fin février début mars 2000 à 2500
tests par jour début avril 5000 tests
par jour euh au moment du déconfinement
au 11 mai entre 40 et 50000 tests par
jour avec une capacité qui a été estimée
qui a été calculée en fin de confinement
sur la base d'un r inférieur à 1 où il y
aurait chaque pour chaque cas positif 10
à 15 cas contact et donc nous avions
défini qu'il fallait que nous nous
soyons en mesure d'atteindre si
nécessaire les 700000 la grande donnée
différente au moment du déconfinement
c'est que au lieu de 10 à 15 cas contact
il y avait entre 2 et 4 cas contact par
patient positif et donc ça ça a changé
ça a changé la donne sur désormais nous
sommes capables d'en faire 1,3 million
et on se sera sans doute capable d'en
faire davantage si nécessaire à
l'avenir sur les tests de télétravail le
sujet des de carence vous avez raison
c'est c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
qui est extrêmement compliqué parce que
selon la situation si vous êtes qu'
contact ou si vous êtes positif selon la
personne qui vous a fait en fait comment
vous dire vous êtes en activité
partielle où vous êtes en arrêt de
travail avec indemnité journalière et et
délai de carrence en fonction des
situations dans lesquelles vous vous
trouvez et ça les structures assurance
maladie les ARS et cetera le savent les
médecins y compris sur le sujet
télétravail doiTent être encouragé de
toute façon à chaque fois qu'on peut le
faire à chaque fois qu'on peut le faire
et encore plus encore quand on est dans
une zone où le virus circule beaucoup le
rôle de SPF dans la crise j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure enfin mon rôle n'est pas
de de tirer à l'arme lourde pour
reprendre votre métaphore guerrière sur
une une agence qui est composée de de
personnes d'expert qui font de leur
mieux depuis le début de la crise et qui
se sont organisés depuis le début de la
crise ça veut pas dire et pour pour
rebondir sur le fait qu'il y aurait pas
de critique ou d'autocritique ou ou ou
qu'on est pas capable de pointer
nous-même le doigt sur des lenteurs sur
des inerties j'ai parler tout à l'heure
de la mauvaise publication des chiffres
des tests qui m'a assez énervé pendant
un moment parce que je c'est compliqué
quand on vous reproche de pas faire de
test parce que les chiffres que vous
sortez vous-même sont en dessous de la
réalité enfin bref vous imaginez bien je
vous ai parlé des couvillons qui sont
emblématiques d'un certain nombre de
lenteur qui sont pas forcément le lié à
la santé publique France d'ailleurs mais
qui ont pu émailler cette gestion de
crise nous reverrons tout cela à
postériori encore une fois moi je suis
au d'une bataille et moi j'ai besoin des
troupes et j'ai besoin que les troupes
soient mobilisées j'ai besoin que les
agences soient totalement mobilisées
qu'elles soient motivées et moi à chaque
fois que j'enregistre des des
dysfonctionnements ou des choses qui ne
vont pas je n'accuse pas encore moins
publiquement j'y vais et je suis allé à
santé publique France avec des visite
qui étaent plus ou moins organisé pour
pouvoir rencontrer tout le monde saisir
les sujets quand il se posaient moi
c'est comme ça que j'envisage le
management en période de crise sur les
soignants qui soient qu'à contact ou
asymptômatique et bien ils doivent être
exclu du travail pendant la la même
période que les autres on avait envisagé
que il pourrait revenir au travail
masqué si tout le système sanitaire
était saturé et que c'était une question
entre guillemets pardonnez-moi pour les
malades de vie ou de mort mais sinon
évidemment qu'ils sont logés à la même
enseigne que les
autres la déclinaison des mesures
annoncées hier je ne vais pas rentrer
dans le détail parce que comme je l'ai
annoncé hier et comme justement on me
reprochait de ne on m'aurait encore plus
reproché si on l'avait pas fait le
c'est le préfet qui est en train de
concerter les élus dans les différents
territoires et qui devra ensuite affiner
les différentes mesures sur les horaires
les modalités d'application et cetera et
cetera sur tout ce qui concerne la
période antérieure au 16 février
pardonnez-moi mais parce que je suis
sous cerment je ne le commenterai pas je
n'ai pas en connaître avec suffisamment
de précision de fait et d'assurance pour
me risquer sous serment à émettre un
avis personnel non seulement mon avis
n'est pas très intéressant mais par
ailleurs vous avez auditionné la
ministre Ministre en charge à cette
époque sur l'articulation hospitalière
public privée j'ai abondamment répondu
puis enfin pour Monsieur Assouline
monsieur assouine monsieur le sénateur
agence de crise pardon monsieur le
ministre agence de crise question
précise de Madame qu'estce que j'ai dit
sur Agence de crise qu'est-ce est-ce que
ce serait utile de créer une agence de
crise spécifique mais j'ai répondu tout
à l'heure j'ai dit que quand on a
fusionné les Prusses avec l'INPES
l'Invest et cetera probablement qu'il
faut revoir cette déclinaison là et de
toute façon vous savez notre pays va
devoir s'armer contre des d'autres types
de crises qui sont pas forcément des
crises épidémiques mais qui vont être
des crises qui vont avoir trait à la
santé environnementale je dire il faut
qu'on puisse s'armer dans les
territoires dans les régions qu'on fasse
de la l'information de la formation de
l'intervention et donc on va revoir ce
dispositif et avec vous avec vous for de
votre expérience je voudrais terminer en
répondant à monsieur assouine assouine
je vous cite tout le monde sait que les
Français le S on nous avait annoncé des
mesures fortesine moi je ne fais jamais
je dis que je ne venez pas ici avec ni
des opinions ni des onies je ne peux pas
me le permettre je suis ministre en
charge de la crise je ne raisonne et je
ne décide qu'à partir des fait je ne
sais pas qui vous a annoncé qu'il y
aurait des mesures fortes au précédent
conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale moi j'en ai vécu plus de 30 il
y en a eu avec des annonces fortes il y
en a eu qui étaiit là pour faire le
point des objectifs et cetera lorsque
vous dites tout le monde le sait très
bien que les masques vous me demander de
faire un parjure monsieur monsieur le
sénateur dans la mesure où je vous ai
répondu en vous disant qu'il y avait pas
de lien entre la doctrine des masques et
la gestion de la pénuie et que vous
dites tout le monde le sait que vous
mentez vous me demandez où vous faites
le constat pararjure au quel cas ça vous
engage ou vous me demander d'en faire un
et je vous répondrai non et je vous ai
répondu sur le
fond les élus qui dénoncent le manque de
concertation c'est pas le manque de
concertation qui dénonce à travers ça
afin de soyons pas DUP c'est la nature
des mesures à chaque fois qu'un élu m'a
dit je ne je n'ai pas été concerté sur
cette mesure quand il est d'accord ça
pose pas de difficulté donc que les élus
qui dénoncent le manque de concertation
dénoncent les mesures que les élus
disent publiquement je considère bien
sûr mais d'ailleurs ils le font donc
concentrons-nous sur le fond des mesures
et pas sur la forme des mesures et non
mais attendez concentrons-nous sur le
fond vous pouvez passer de semaines à
consulter les uns et les autres sur une
mesure si vous ne tombez pas d'accord à
la fin il y a ceux qui diront j'ai
consulté concerté je décide parce que
gouverner sait choisir et je protège et
les autres qui diront on n' pas été
consulté concerté puisqu'on a pas gagné
mais attendez mais mais je vous ai donné
l'exemple marseillais et les 2 heures
passé à la préfecture et les semaines et
les semaines passer à alerter à
sensibiliser en disant attention
attention donc pardonnez-moi mais ils
ont le droit de contester des mesures et
ils ont parfaitement le droit de compter
ces des mesures nous sommes en droit de
les demander dans la dans la mesure où
justement elle montre que ell réduisent
l'épidémie des études qui montrre que il
y a quatre fois plus de risque d'être
contaminé au covid quand on a fréquenté
un bar dans les jours avant que quand on
n pas fréquenté de bar je n'y peux rien
et je je fréquente enfin je fréquentais
quand j'avais le temps les bars et les
restaurants et c'est il s'agit pas d'un
criminé qui que ce soit c'est c'est un
c'est un fait qui est complexe c'est un
fait qui est complexe et qui participe
de la diffusion de l'épidémie la enfin
pour Monsieur Assouline la la loi
prévoit que la police sanitaire est une
compétence de l'État Premier ministre
euh MSS ministre de solidarité de la
santé préfet c'est le choix du du
Premier ministre et du choix du
gouvernement donc voilà je peux le dire
j'entends j'entends parfaitement les
critiques j'entends parfaitement les
remises en question j'entends
parfaitement qu'un maire a envie de
défendre la vie sociale dans sa commune
les bars et les restaurants j'entends
aussi les maires qui tout en défendant
la vie sociale et la vie économique dans
leur commune me disent c'est la bonne
décision à prendre aujourd'hui pour
protéger les habitants parce que ça ça
se passe mal au niveau de la diffusion
épidémique donc vous avez des maires
c'est pas une question de politique
puisque je vous ai cité un certain
nombre de maires issus du même parti que
la mère de Marseille ou clamer de Paris
qui considère que toute mesure
nécessaire dès lors qu'elle est
justifiée elle n'est pas à discuter donc
je je dis pas que c'est pas dur et je me
mets à la place des Marseillais et je
sais qu'il y a des gens qui sont en
colère je je je vais comme vous sur les
réseaux sociaux ENF je n'y vais plus
parce que c'est surtout après des
soirées comme celle-ci je suis pas
masochiste mais mais honnêtement tout ce
qui est fait est fait pour pouvoir
assurer la protection des gens et si on
voit que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore nous l'avons déjà fait dire
personnea critiqué en Mayenne au mois de
juillet quand il y avait une reprise
épidémique et qu'on a mis en place des
mesures de restriction de rassemblement
qu'on a mis des mesures de couvre-feu
personne n'a critiqué ce qui a été fait
en Mayenne vous pouvez me rappeler ce
qui s'est passé en Mayenne en Mayenne
l'épidémie elle a faitlac et l'impact
sanitaire il a été extrêmement faible et
j'y suis allé et en guyan pareil les
mesures de couvre-feu les mesures de
gestion quand ça commenca à flamber et
on a réussi à enrayer l'épidémie il y a
pas de raison qu'on puisse pas le faire
à Marseille comme sur tout autre
territoire de la République encore une
fois c'est le seul objectif qui est le
nôtre c'est protéger la santé des
Français
non mais on va pasonger le débat mais il
y a un point qu'on souhaitait aborder
avec vous mais ça va être très long et
c'est pas c'était le problème de la
vaccination antigripale est-ce que vous
allez la rendre
obligatoire la vaccination antigripal
parce que ça va se cumuler avec avec le
covid c'était mon c'est une question
tout à fait essentielle merci Catherine
effectivement on se l'
posé moi c'était c'était une précision
pour qu'il pas mal entendu quand sur sur
les mesures et je je je demandais de la
cohérence comment expliquez-vous par
exemple c'est voilà c'est une question
qu'un français pourrait vous poser là
puisque je l'ai vu comme ça poser
brutalement et j'étais pas capable de
répondre dans les mesures prises euh
l'activité sportive est interdite elle
doit pas être très importante pour
l'économie donc une une dame dit ma
fille euh qui fait de la danse dans une
grande salle où il y a 10 euh mumes
est-ce passé de suffisamment n'a plus le
droit de faire la danse par contre elle
peut aller en classe où ils sont 30
entassés dans la classe qu'est-ce que je
réponds qu'est-ce que vous répondez
merci agès Préville Angèle Angèle mais
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai pas
eu la réponse et je ne doute pas de la
bonne volonté je vous ai demandé au
moment où on on met en isolement les
épad est-ce qu'il y a eu dans les
consignes le fait qu'un livreur même
devait être protégé et que non seulement
les soignants mais également tout le
reste du personnel devait avoir des
équipements de protection c'était ma
question merci Monsieur le Ministre
trois réponses courtes un madame pardon
si j'ai mal répondu à votre question non
seulement il devit protégé mais il
pouvait pas rentrer donc la question se
pose pas merci deuxème question pourquoi
salle de sport je suis ministre de la
Santé je je je crois sincèrement au
bien-être du sport au bienfait du sport
sur la santé donc serait à nouveau hélas
dans les salles de sport il y a de la
transpiration il y a des a des jets de
gouttelettes il y a des mouvements et il
y a des contaminations qui se font
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus dans
certains contextes que dans d'autres et
notamment que dans le milieu
professionnel où la la distanciation le
masque et l'absence de transpiration
joueci souine par contre vous poser une
question je l'ai dit hier soir ça
peut-être pas été perçu dans le flot de
d'annonce mais s'agissant des gymnases
et des salles de sport je n'ai pas dit
que les gymnases seraiit interdit pour
les enfants en scolaire par exemple j'ai
dit que tout cela fait partie des
mesures discutées en concertation entre
les préfets et les
élus donc dans les zones qui sont
concernées dans les zones qui dans les
zones qui sont cenées les salles de
sport les salles de sport il y a les
salles de sport clairement pour qui
concerne les adultes avec parfois une
forte concentration de personnes dans
une même pièce avec de la transpiration
des gouttelettes qui se déposent là on
sait que c'est hélas encore une fois pas
bon mais vous avez des gymnases qui sont
accessibles aux enfants dans dans le
domaine scolaire qui qui peuvent
éventuellement être amenés donc voyez
quand on parle de conceration en fait
elle existe puis que j'ai pas la réponse
à la question que vous me posez selon le
territoire concerné et selon l'issue de
la concertation c'est un point qui est
important et enfin c'était sur la
grippe beaucoup de questions sur la
grippe et je m'en réjouis la campagne
antigrippale elle commence le 13 octobre
comme chaque année elle commencera pas
avant puisque si on vaccine trop tôt le
vaccin perd en efficacité dans la durée
et donc il ne protégerait pas au bon
moment par ailleurs nous avons déjà
le les conclusions de l'épisode grippal
dans l'hémisphère sud qui montre que la
grippe a été un retardé donc
habituellement elle intervient en France
à partir du 20 décembre il y a des
raisons de penser qu'elle interviendra
encore plus tard de elle a été faible
masque geste barrière en surtout gestes
barrière d'ailleurs parce que le masque
les études montrent que ça marche pas
trop là-dessus mais vous avez le masque
vous avez le les gestes barrières la
distanciation sociale et l'attention qui
est portée puis un mécanisme peut-être
de compétition entre le la grippe et le
covid qui utilise un récepteur un peu
similaire pour rentrer donc néanmoins
nous devons faire extrêmement attention
à la vaccination des publics vulnérables
et des soignants dans notre pays c'est
une c'est un c'est une cible qui est
importante et donc la campagne vaccinale
nous nous mettrons évidemment l'accent
sur le sujet pour la première fois en
plus des commandes des officines nous
avons procédé à des sécurisations de
commandes d'État et nous avons 30 % de
dos de vaccin en plus que les années
précédentes 30 % et il ce sera un vrai
enjeu que la vaccination des soignants
je prends un retour de retour sur la
Réunion me semble-t-il que les soignants
en épad on n'a pas dépassé les 30 % de
couverture vaccinale antigrippale donc
ça c'est un vrai sujet l'obligation
passerait je pense par la loi monsieur
le sénateur je ne suis même pas sûr que
si nous voulions le faire nous aurions
le temps dans les délais imparties euh
dans les les derniè parties de le faire
en tout cas c'est nous allons avoir une
stratégie affinée en matière de
vaccination antigripal qui passe par la
Autorité de Santé et nous tenons prêt
Catherine Desroches non il faudra
bien se poser la question de
l'obligation des soignants on en parle
depuis des années il faut une vraie
volonté c'est l'exemple monsieur le
ministre qu'il faudrait donner à travers
la grippe pour que nos consitoyens
comprendre l'intérêt de vaccination
demain on l'espère à travers le covid
c'est pour ça que nous sommes fort
intéressés avec cette campagne de
vaccination merci en tout cas de votre
patience mes chers commissaires merci
monsieur le ministre pour V réponse donc
je clos la
séance
pour cette audition d'Olivier verrant
l'actuel ministre de la santé était
auditionné par la commission d'enquête
consacrée à l'épidémie de coronavirus
Olivier Verant vient en quelque sorte
clore un cycle une séquence puisque
plusieurs membres actuels ou passés de
l'exécutif ont été entendus ces derniers
jours ce weekend c'est les sénatoriales
il faudra ensuite procéder aux
nominations au sein des différentes
commissions la commission d'enquête sur
le covid est bien évidemment concerné on
suivra ça sur public scénna reste avec
nous l'information politique et
parlementairire continue sur notre
antenne